ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL I AGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA POWER QUE HAN.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU JUNE DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY D. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
SUCI DOES AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY. THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEEN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
OKAY MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A CAR IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS. IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PETRIE-NORRIS ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
LORD WE ARE IN A MOMENT AS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS. A
DEVASTATING PANDEMIC FIRES
RAGING ACROSS OUR STATE AN
ECONOMY IN FREE FALL AND
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS ON THE
BRINK. WONDERING HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE RENT PAY THEIR
BILLS AND FEED THEIR BABIES.
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE ENTRUSTED US WITH AN
AWESOME AND A DAUNTING
RESPONSIBILITY. TO LEAD THROUGH
THIS CRISIS TO NAVIGATE THESE
TROUBLED WATERS AND TO SET A
GREAT STATE ON A PATH TO
RECOVERY. WE COME TOGETHER
TODAY WITH MERE DAYS TO DO THE
WORK OF A GENERATION. WE NEED
YOUR HELP. LORD YOU HAVE TAUGHT
US IN TIMES STRIFE IN TIMES OF
ADVERSITY IN OUR DARKEST HOUR
TO SEARCH FOR YOU THAT YOU ARE
OUR REFUGE AND OUR STRENGTH.
WELL LOWER WOULD NEED YOUR
REFUGE RIGHT NOW WE REALLY NEED
YOUR STRENGTH. LORD WE ARE
PROFOUNDLY GRATEFUL GRATEFUL
BEYOND THE POWER OF MY WORDS
FOR OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK
RUNNING ON FUMES RISKING THEIR
OWN LIVES TO KEEP US SAFE. MAY
THEY HAVE YOUR PROTECTION MADE
A FEEL YOUR STRENGTH MADE A
KNOW YOUR PIECE. AND LORD IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS AND MONTHS
AHEAD. AS GIVE EACH ONE OF US
WISDOM THE BEST PATIENTS AND
GIVE US FORTITUDE. SO THAT WE
MAY BUILD BACK HOW STRONGER
THAN BEFORE. THANK YOU MISS
PETER NORRIS YES OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER ONE. THANK YOU
PLEASE JOIN ME FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE ALAS. ISRAEL. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE ELEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY SOME OF IT NOT A ON THE
ON WILL COVER MULLIN SPEAKER
VOTING FOR THE ASSEMBLY CHIEF
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OBERNOLTE FOR MEDICAL
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER.
FOR MATERNITY LEAVE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WICKS.
MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS KILEY BURKE
ARAMBULA MEDINA WEBER KAMLAGER
GALLAGHER DOLLY AND CHIU CHOW
TO SPEAK ON A JOURNEY MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
FOLLOWING FOR MANAGERS ARE
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE TO
REMOVE BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM A THREE SB ONE
SEVENTY NINE NIELSEN BY
RODRIGUEZ. I AM A NINE SB SIXTY
A GALGIANI BY SOMEONE MEMBER
HOLDEN. ITEM A THIRTEEN SB SIX
SIXTY EIGHT CENTER RUBIO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO ITEM A
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN FORTY NINE-
ALSO AN ITEM A SIXTEEN S. B.
FIFTY FOUR ALLEN. BOTH BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. GONZALEZ
MADISON WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR I DON'T
WANNA SEVEN ESPYS FOURTEEN
SEVENTY THREE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE FINANCE AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
SB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX JONES AT
THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER I DON'T WANT
EIGHTEEN SB TWELVE FORTY FOUR
BRADFORD. AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA ITEM ONE
TWENTY FOUR SB EIGHT SIXTY NINE
SENATE GEOCHEMISTRY AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
I DON'T WANT TWENTY SEVEN SB
TEN THIRTY SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. ADAM ONE
FORTY S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
SEVEN BRADFORD AT THE REQUEST
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOAN AND
ITEM ONE FORTY ONE SB SIX SEVEN
REQUIRE AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX IN ALL WITHDRAW
SB EIGHT NINETEEN SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL TO
THE THIRD READING FILE FOR
TOMORROW. MR FLOOR FOR A
PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD EMAILS
PERCENT NATURAL CALL VOTE.
MISTER FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING
MISTER CALDERON MOVES TO MR
BONTA SECONDS ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. CLARK WELL
WITH THE ROLE CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTES. MISTER
FLORES ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON. IT'S ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR FLORA
NO ON THE PROCEDURAL MATTER.
MISTER CALDERON ASKING FOR NINE
MISTER FLORA NO. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL EYES FORTY TWO THOSE
TWELVE. THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
YEAH.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THERE
IS A RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK RELATIVE TO SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BRADFORD I ASK
THAT WE GO TO THAT ITEM NOW. MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR WE OBJECT
AND ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS.
ON THIS RULE WAIVER. MEMBERS
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS ON THE SUSPENSION
OF THE CHOI ROLE. CALGARY THE
WRESTLING RESULT JOINT WILL
SIXTY BB SUSPENDED TO REMIT
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MEET
CONSIDER AND REPORT SENATE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY ONE FOR FURTHER
ACTION. THE MOTION MISTER
CALDERON HAS MOVED IN MR BONTA
SECOND ON THE PROCEDURAL MATTER
BEFORE THE BODY CLERK WILL.
WITH THE ROLE. TAKES FIFTY FOUR
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN I. AND MR FLORA NO MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I.
MISTER FLORA. I KNOW. THIS WILL
TAKE A.
FIFTY FOUR. MISTER
CALDERON MOVES A CALL.
MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE I MOVE TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO WAY TO
FALL KNOWS CRIME AND TO ALLOW
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO
HEAR SB SEVEN FOUR SEVENTY NINE
ATKINS ON WEDNESDAY UPON
CULTURE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I AM
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILL.
I'M AT ONE SB FOUR SEVENTY NINE
ATKINS TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
OUR MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. MEMBERS I AM GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL ON THE PROCEDURAL
MATTER THAT IS. CURRENTLY ON
CALL THE JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
SUSPENSION CORP WILL POST.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THIS CALL AROUND ASKING
FOR AN I.
MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
PROCEDURAL MATTER.
ALL MEMBERS
HER DESIRE TO VOTE. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I. MR
FLOORS ASKING FOR NO.
MISTER
CALDERON TESTING FOR NYE THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR MEMBERS.
MISTER CALDERON REPLACES THE
CALL. MEMBERS JUST- FYI WE ARE
WORKING ON FIXING THE AIR
CONDITIONING ON THE FLOOR. WE
ARE WORKING ON THE AIR
CONDITIONING.
ONE MEDINA
MEMBERS WANNA LIVE THE CALL
AGAIN ON THE BRIDGE ITEM FOR
PROPOSED. MISTER CALDERON FOR
NINE. AND MISTER FLORA IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE ON THE
PROCEDURAL MOTION.
WELL CLOSER
ROLE TODD ABOUT ICT FOR KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE JOINT ROLE IS
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEM SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTY FOUR ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX. A. B.
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO THIRTY
FOUR WITH A MINUTES BY
SUBMITTING. MISTER CHANG ON THE
AMENDMENTS MEMBERS. PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION MR TANG MISTER
KING THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'M PRESENTING AMENDMENTS TO AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR TODAY
THAT WILL REMOVE SEX OFFENSES
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENSES
FROM THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION PROGRAMS
IN THE BILL. THE MEMBER JUST AS
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES ABOUT FLORIDA
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES FOR AB THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR FOR THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER TANK. C.
NOTIFICATION OF BAIT AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINTED BACK ON FILE. AND
NOW MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN. AB THIRTY THREE
THIRTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
A MEASURE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE THIRTY WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME REMEMBER CALDERON. MISTER
CALDERON ON THE MENACE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THE MEMBERS
OF THE BILL REDUCE THE FEES
FROM TWELVE DOLLARS TO THE LEFT
TO ELEVEN DOLLARS AND REMOVES
ALL OPPOSITION. STOCKLEY
ASTRONAUT VOTES FOR THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. C. NOTIFICATION OF IT
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOTTED. HOW
TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS THIS IS SECOND READING
CORPORATION SENATE BILL. NINE
SEVENTY FOUR TEN TWENTY NINE
WITH A MINUTES EIGHTY SIX ONE
FORTY TWO OH THREE TO EIGHTY
BEFORE TWO THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
SO THIRTY NINE SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN THREE A. NINETY FIVE NINE
FOURTEEN NINE TWENTY ONE NINE
THIRTY FOUR NINE SEVEN TWO NINE
SEVEN 311-159-1180 NINE
ELEVEN NINETY SIX WILL. SEVEN
TWELVE TWENTY THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE FOURTEEN OH NINE FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE FOURTE BILL TO FOURTEEN WITH A
MINUTES TO SEVENTY FIVE THE
MINUTES THREE SIXTY NINE FOR
THE MINUTES FOUR SIX FOR THE
MINUTES. FOUR NINETY THREE WITH
A MINUTE'S FIVE FIFTY FIVE OF
THE MEMBERS FIVE NINETY TWO THE
MINUTES FIVE NINETY SIX OF THE
MOMENT SIX SIXTY SEVEN WITH A
MEMBER SEVEN TWENTY NINE OF THE
MINUTES SEVEN FORTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE FIFTY EIGHT WITH A
MINUTE SEVEN SEVEN SIX MINUTES
IT'LL FREE WITH A MEMBERS A
FIFTY TWO WITH A MEMBERS A
FIFTY FIVE THE MINUTES. A.
SIXTY FIVE- THE MINUTES NOT
AWAY WITH IMMENSE NINE TWELVE
MINUTES NINETY THREE WITH A
MINUTES TEN FORTY FOUR WITH A
MINUTES TEN SIXTY FOUR THE
MEMBERS TEN SIXTY FIVE OF THE
MEMBERS TEN EIGHTY FIVE OF THE
MEMBERS ELEVEN ELEVEN WITH A
MINUTES ELEVEN THIRTY WITH A
MINUTES ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
MINUTES ELEVEN FIFTY SIX FOR
THE MOMENTS LEADING SEVENTY
THREE WITH A MINUTE TO LET IN
SOME FIVE MINUTES. TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN WITH A MINSTREL
FIFTY SEVEN WITH A MINUTES
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN ON ONE OF THE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN TWENTY WITH A MINUTES
THIRTY FORTY ONE OF THE MEMBERS
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT MINUTES
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS THIRTEEN NINETY NINE
WITH LIMITS AND SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOR THE
MINUTES. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN.
READ AMENDMENTS TO. ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON FOR PROFESSOR
HI THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW SOMEONE MEMBER WOULD TO
TAKE ABOUT ELEVEN SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE HILL WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FOLLOW THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD READING. MISTER FLORA
FOR PURPOSE WE WITHHOLDING
EVIDENCE ENOUGH FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES ON THE ROLE SUSPENSION.
SECONDED BY MR BONTA. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR
NO VOTE MISTER CALDERON. IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR
FLORA NO. WELL. CLOSE ROLE I
FIFTY THREE KNOWS. THIRTEEN THE
MOTION CARRIES.
UHHUH MEMBERS.
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THIS
IS. SENATE BILL. SEVEN NINETY
THREE. MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY SUPERHERO ANOTHER'S
AND ACCOLADES TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS AND
KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE WE HAVE LOTS OF
BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY THIS
WEEK. AND PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO DOCTOR WOULD
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAIL BEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE SENATE BILL SEVEN
NINETY THREE BY SENATOR HILL.
SB SEVEN NINETY THREE IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES PARENTS
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY YOUNG
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA PLANNED
PARENTHOOD THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION KAISER AND
MY PERSONAL FAVORITE THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
ALL PROPONENTS OF PROP FIFTY
SIX WHICH INCREASE THE TO PAY
TAXES ON TOBACCO A FEW YEARS
BACK. ACCORDING TO THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION MORE THAN
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR
WORLDWIDE ARE KILLED BY THE
TOBACCO PRODUCTS IT'S THE MOST
DEADLY CONSUMER PRODUCT EVER
CREATED. THIS IS. MEMBERS.
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION TO DOCTOR
WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I'LL SAY AGAIN ACCORDING TO THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
TOBACCO KILLS MORE THAN EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE A YEAR WORLDWIDE
IT IS THE MOST DEADLY CONSUMER
PRODUCT EVER CREATED TOBACCO
USE IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
PREVENTABLE DISEASE DISABILITY
AND DEATH IN THE UNITED STATES.
MORE THAN SIXTEEN MILLION
AMERICANS ARE LIVING WITH THE
SMOKING CAUSES CANCER HEART
DISEASE AND LUNG DISEASES
DIABETES AND CHRONIC CHRONIC
OBSTRUCTIVE PULMONARY DISEASE
WHICH INCLUDES EMPHYSEMA AND
CHRONIC BRONCHITIS THE STATE
SPENDS OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR ON THE TREATMENT
OF SMOKING RELATED RELATED
ILLNESSES IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
ALONE WHILE OVERALL HEALTH
EXPENDITURES ON THIS IS OVER
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE NUMBER
AND SMOKERS IN CALIFORNIA IS
LOWER THAN IT HAS BEEN IN MANY
YEARS THAT MEANS BIG TOBACCO IS
WORKING HARDER THAN EVER TO
TRACK THE NEXT GENERATION OF TO
THEIR DEADLY. IN 201867% OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO USED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS IN THE LAST
THIRTY DAYS REPORTED USING A
FLAVORED PRODUCT ONE OF THE
MOST PIC PUT POPULAR FLAVOURS
IS MENTHOL. THE CDC SAYS QUOTE
TOBACCO COMPANIES USE ADMIN
PAUL TO MAKE CIGARETTES SEEM
LESS HARSH AND MORE APPEALING
TO NEW SMOKERS AND YOUNG AND
QUOTE I SPENT MY ENTIRE
PROFESSIONAL CAREER TRYING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM THE RAVAGES
OF TOBACCO ADDICTION I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND GUN DISEASE TOOTH
LOSS IN ORAL CANCER STUDY SO
SHE DID WAS SMOKING AND
SMOKELESS TOBACCO PRODUCTS.
I'LL NEVER FORGET SOME PATIENTS
WHO EVEN WHILE UNDERGOING
CHEMOTHERAPY AND RADIATION FROM
PRINT CANCER SOCI WITH TOBACCO
CONTINUE TO SMOKE THEY JUST
COULDN'T QUIT. YOU KNOW I'VE
NEVER MET SOMEONE WHO SAID THE
BEST DECISION I EVER MADE WAS
TO START SMOKING I LOVE WAKING
UP IN THE MORNING AND COUGHING
AS I REACH FOR THAT FIRST SMOKE
I. REALLY ENJOY THE FACT THAT
IT TAKES ME LONGER TO GET OVER
A COLD. I LOVE THE FRESH HOW
FRESH MY HOUSE IN MY CAR SMELL
MY CLOTHES SMELL AFTER I'VE
BEEN SMOKING. INSTEAD MORE THAN
90% OF SMOKERS WISH THEY'D
NEVER STARTED. NINE OUT OF TEN
SMART- SMOKERS START BEFORE THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND NINETY NINE
PERCENT. BY THE AGE OF TWENTY
SIX. AND FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS ARE A HUGE CONTRIBUTOR
TO THIS. THIS BILL WILL BAN THE
SALE OF FLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS IN RETAIL STORES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS INCLUDES
VAPING PRODUCTS IN THOSE LITTLE
CIGARS THE SECOND MOST POPULAR
PRODUCT AMONG HIGH SCHOOLERS
WITH FLAVORS LIKE MANGO
TROPICAL FUSION IN CHOCOLATE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MORE. EASEL
CIGARS OFFERS LOW AS A DOLLAR
FORTY NINE FOR TWO OF THE
SECOND MOST POPULAR PRODUCT
AMONG HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN
BIG TOBACCO IS WORKING HARD TO
MAINTAIN THE ABILITY TO SELL
THESE. WELL THE OPPOSITION IS
BENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FIGHTING THIS LEGISLATION POINT
TO THE EXEMPTIONS MADE ALONG
THE WAY. THE COURT THIS BILL
DESIGNED TO PROTECT KIDS
REMAINS INTACT. IN A PERFECT
WORLD THERE WOULD BE NO
EXEMPTIONS IN THIS BILL BUT WE
ALL KNOW WE DON'T LIVE IN A
PERFECT WORLD. WHETHER IT'S
VAPING SMOKELESS TOBACCO
CIGARETTES ARE SMALL CIGARS WE
KNOW THE FLAVORS ATTRACT KIDS
THE NEXT GENERATIONS OF SMOKERS
AT BIG TOBACCO NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO PEDDLE THEIR DEADLY
PRODUCTS. THE CHOICE IS SIMPLE
IT'S PRETTY SIMPLE TO ME
ANYWAY. VOTE YES TO HELP
PROTECT KIDS OR VOTE NO. TO
PROTECT BIG TOBACCO THE CHOICE
IS YOURS. I'D SAY ONE MORE
THING THAT'S RELATED TO
POTENTIAL LOSS OF TAX REVENUE
WITH WHICH I'VE HEARD THE
OPPOSITION SPEAK UP. SHOULD
THIS BILL PASS AGAIN I WOULD
NOTE THAT. ALL OF THE COALITION
SUPPORTERS FOR PROP FIFTY SIX
THE MOST RECENT TOBACCO TAX
LEGISLATION ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT HAD BEEN WORKING WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM MERCED
WHO IS LOOKING AT A BEIPING TAX
IT MAY NOT HAPPEN THIS YEAR BUT
I'M COMMITTED TO WORK WITH HIM
ON ON I BUT I AGREE WITH THE
STRUCTURE. AND ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISMS THAT GO ALONG WITH
THAT HELLO IF WE CAN'T DO THIS
YEAR I LOOK FORWARD TO MAKING
THAT A REALITY IN A TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SECONDS
DOCTOR WITH WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THE TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL FOR
HUGE DOWNSTREAM SAVINGS ON
HEALTH CARE COSTS TO TREAT
TOBACCO RELATED TO DISEASES. I
WOULD ACTUALLY CONSIDER THE
REVENUE LOSS AS AN INVESTMENT
PREVENTION FOR THE FUTURE OF
THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIANS.
SOMETHING WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
DO MORE OF IN THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR WAIT. MISTER
BLOWN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
TOBACCO RELATED ISSUES FOR MY
ENTIRE CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE
IT'S NOW OVER TWENTY YEARS.
TOBACCO IS AN ADDICTIVE POISON
AND THE INDUSTRY MODEL DEPENDS
IT DEPENDS. ON HOOKING PEOPLE
AT AN EARLY AGE. THE RANGE OF
LONG TERM HEALTH ISSUES ARISING
FROM TOBACCO USE AND SECONDHAND
SMOKE IS WELL KNOWN TO ALL OF
YOU AND WELL RESEARCHED
CURRENTLY WE ARE LEARNING MORE
AND MORE ABOUT THE
COMORBIDITIES OF COVERT
NINETEEN AND COMPROMISED
RESPIRATORY SYSTEMS. IS ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT. GETTING
YOUNG PEOPLE HOOKED ON CANDY
FLAVORED TOBACCO PUTS THEM IN
JEOPARDY NOW. AND POSSIBLY FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIVES. THE
TOBACCO COMPANIES KNOW THAT
ALMOST ALL NEW TOBACCO USERS
BEGIN THEIR ADDICTION AS KIDS.
BUT THEY ALSO NOTE THAT TO
NOVICE SMOKERS TOBACCO CAN BE
HARSH AND UNAPPEALING AN
INTERNAL TOBACCO INDUSTRY
DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT TOBACCO
COMPANIES HAVE A LONG HISTORY
OF USING FLAVORS TO REDUCE THE
HARSHNESS OF THEIR PRODUCTS TO
MAKE THEM MORE APPEALING TO NEW
USERS. ALMOST ALL OF WHOM ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN BY
MASKING THE HARSHNESS AND
SOOTHING THE IRRITATION CAUSED
BY TOBACCO SMOKE FLAVORS MAKE
IT EASIER FOR BEGINNERS
PRIMARILY KIDS TO TRY THE
PRODUCT AND ULTIMATELY
ULTIMATELY BECOME ADDICTED. THE
COST OF CARE FOR TOBACCO
RELATED ILLNESSES TO OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM AND INSURANCE
PROGRAMS IT'S ASTRONOMICAL.
SIMILARLY THE MISERY CAUSED BY
THE SAME ILLNESSES ALONG WITH
SHORTENED LIFE EXPECTANCIES IS
AN ABOMINATION. ACCORDING TO
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
AND NATIONAL CANCER INSTITUTE
SMOKING AND ITS SIDE EFFECTS
COST THE WORLD'S ECONOMIES MORE
THAN ONE TRILLION DOLLARS AND
KILL ABOUT SIX MILLION PEOPLE
EVERY YEAR. THE ECONOMIC COST
OF TOBACCO USE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
AND INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CARE COSTS FOR TREATING TOBACCO
RELATED DISEASES. AND THE LOST
PRODUCTIVITY THAT RESULTS FROM
TOBACCO ATTRIBUTABLE MORBIDITY
AND MORTALITY. A STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO FOUND THAT OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS THE
CALIFORNIA TOBACCO CONTROL
PROGRAM OUR PROGRAM. HAS
REDUCED ACTUAL MEDICAL COSTS BY
AN ASTONISHING FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS THIS AMOUNT
ONLY INCLUDES MEDICAL CARE
COSTS DOCTORS HOSPITALS DRUGS
AND RELATED COSTS AND NOT
INDIRECT COSTS SUCH AS LOST
PRODUCTIVITY OR THE VALUE OF
LIVES LOST. WERE WHO ARE THE
VALUE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH DISEASE. THE
SAVINGS IN THOSE AREAS OR EVEN
GENERALLY EVEN MORE THAN THE
DIRECT MEDICAL COSTS. LIKE
PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO REDUCE
TOBACCO CONSUMPTION.
RESTRICTING THE SALE OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS WOULD
BE A PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
VICTORY FOR CALIFORNIA. SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE WOULD SAVE
AT LEAST SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
LIVES AND EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN HEALTH CARE COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BLEMISH MCCARTY YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM THE NORTH COAST AND FROM
SANTA MONICA OUTLINED IT'S JUST
A FEW OUTSTANDING ISSUES. THE
FIRST IS THIS IS NOT THE
PERFECT BILLY WANTED BUT IT
ADDRESSES 5% OF WHAT WE WANT
AND THESE MISLEADING ADS FROM
BIG TOBACCO MAKE IT SEEM LIKE
WE'RE IGNORING THE INTEREST OF
WHEREKIDS ARE SMOKING. THE
THREE EXEMPTIONS THAT WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO PUT UP.
KIDS REALLY AREN'T GOING TO
HOOK A LOUNGE AS WE HAVE TO BE
ABOVE AGE TO USE IT. FOR NOT
FOCUSING ON PREMIER CIGARS AND
PIPE PRODUCTS IT'S THE VAPING
FLAVORED VAPING WE KNOW THAT
MEANT ALL AS A GATEWAY AND SO
MANY OF OUR URBAN COMMUNITIES.
SO THIS IS REALLY THE FOCUS AS
FAR AS HOW WE WANT TO PREVENT.
YOUTH SMOKING. I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE THING THAT REALLY I
THINK DRIVES ME THAT THE MOST
NOTS WHEN I SEE THESE CRAZY
ADDS THIS IS GONNA HURT
FUNDING. FOR KIDS IN OUR
SCHOOLS THAT'S THIS IS THAT
OUTRIGHT LIE. FIRST NUMBER ONE
SCHOOLS ARE 1100% FUNDED BY
PROP NINETY EIGHT. ZERO IMPACT
ON DOLLARS FROM TOBACCO TAXES.
THE TOBACCO TAXES THAT DO COME
FOR FUN THINGS LIKE FIRST FIVE.
PROGRAMS RESERVE THROUGH FIVE
SOME HEALTH PROGRAMS THERE THE
FIRST FIVE COMMISSIONS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THEY
WOULD LIKE NOTHING MORE THAN TO
GO OUT OF BUSINESS THEY'VE BEEN
DECLINING IN REVENUE ON A
YEARLY BASIS THEY KNOW THAT.
THEIR FOR AT THEIR EXPENDITURES
ARE NOT ONGOING THEY KNOW THAT
THIS IS A DECLINING REVENUE
SOURCE THEY'RE IN FULL CONTROL
THEY'RE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS. IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
ONE THING YOU CAN DO AS FAR AS
TOBACCO EDUCATION. THE
OPPONENTS BIG TOBACCO THINKS
KEEP THIS IN PLACE TO PROTECT
KIDS. THE FOCUS ON ANTI TOBACCO
EDUCATION WELL THE THING THAT'S
THE MOST TO ANTI TOBACCO IS
BANNING THE PRODUCT IN THE
FIRST PLACE TO STOP THE KIDS
FROM GETTING HOOKED IN THE
FIRST PLACE. THIS IS WHAT THIS
IS ALL ABOUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE TRICKED BY. THIS THESE
OUTRAGEOUS ADS WITH THE UP AN
DOWN CALIFORNIA. OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERTS KNOW THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO THIS IS THE
TIME FOR THIS AND THIS IS TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA TO REALLY STEP
UP AND PROTECT ARGUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MCCARTY DR.
ARAMBULA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE NOT ONLY HAS A DOCTOR
THAT HAS WITNESSED FIRST HAND
THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF SMOKING
BUT ALSO AS THE CHAIR OF THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. MEMBERS OF
MY COMMITTEE YOU KNOW THAT WE
SPEND HOURS UPON HOURS
LISTENING THE PASSIONATE AND
HEARTFELT PLEAS FOR RESOURCES
FROM HUNDREDS OF WORTHY GROUPS
AND THOUSANDS OF WORTHY CAUSES.
I LOVE MY COMMITTEE ON THE
ISSUES WE COVER BUT IT IS HARD
BECAUSE WE NEVER HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO FUND ALL THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TO MY SURPRISE I
HAVE HEARD THE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WHO USE WHAT I THINK
IS A BIZARRE AND A DESPERATE
CLAIM AS A REASON TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THEY SAY YOU
SHOULDN'T VOTE FOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL NOT ALLOW
PUBLIC HEALTH GROUPS LIKE FIRST
FIVE AND OTHERS FROM BEING ABLE
TO DO THE VALUABLE AND
SUBSTANTIVE WORK IN THEIR
COMMITTEES THEY GO ON TO SAY
THAT THIS WILL PUT PRESSURE ON
THE GENERAL FUND AND OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. WELL FIRST LET'S
BE CLEAR. BY THE FACT THAT IFTHIS BILL PASSES LESS PEOPLE
WILL BECOME ADDICTED TO TOBACCO
AND LESS PEOPLE FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME WILL SMOKE. OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM WILL GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM THE REDUCTION IN
THE ENORMOUS COST OF DEALING
WITH THE HELP EFFORTS ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO SMOKE. AND OUR
STATE WILL ACTUALLY SAVE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
BUT LET'S PUT THAT ASIDE AND
DELVE DEEPER INTO THE FIRST
CLAIM. I AM SURE A LOT OF YOU
GOT A LETTER FROM CMA FROM CDA
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD IN
KAISER. THE PEOPLE WHO SPEND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PUTTING
PROP FIFTY SIX ON THE BALLOT IN
SECURING ITS PASSAGE. THESE ARE
ALSO THE GROUPS THAT COME TO MY
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH OTHERS AND
VERY PASSIONATELY MAKE REQUEST.
ON HOW TO SPEND PROP FIFTY SIX
MONEY ON ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
COSTS. THEY MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT IF THE RESULT OF THIS BILL
IS LESS CHILDREN BECOMING
ADDICTED TO SMOKING. AND THAT
RESULTS IN LESS REVENUE FOR
THEIR PRIORITIES THEN THE
PURPOSE OF PROP FIFTY SIX IS
WORKING AND THEN SUPPORTING
THIS BILL IS A NO BRAINER.
FIRST FIVE THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION THE CANCER
ASSOCIATION THE HEART
ASSOCIATION I COULD GO ON AND
ON BUT THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND
FORTY DIFFERENT GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS. IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ALL OF WHICH COME
BEFORE MY COMMITTEE AND ASK FOR
MONEY. YET ALL OF THEM ARE
SAYING WITHOUT QUESTION AND
WITHOUT HESITATION THAT THE
BEST THING TO DO FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EVEN PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE FUNDING IS TO PROTECT
THESE KIDS. BREAK THE NASTY
CYCLE OF LETTING CHILDREN BEING
TARGETED BY BIG TOBACCO AND TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL. IF
THERE TRULY IS LESS MONEY THAN
THEIR MISSION IS WORKING THE
MISSION OF THESE GROUPS IS NOT
TO GET MONEY FROM THE STATE. IT
IS TO PREVENT MORE PEOPLE FROM
SMOKING AND BETTER FUNCTIONING
HELPED HAVING A BETTER
FUNCTIONING HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
BUT DO YOU KNOW WHO DOESN'T
COME TO MY COMMITTEE ASKING FOR
MONEY. THE TOBACCO COMPANIES
WHO ARE OPPOSING THIS BILL.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH SO DON'T LET THEM FOOL
YOU WITH THEIR ADVERTISING
CAMPAIGNS. THE OPPOSITION
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH AT ALL. THEY'RE DRIVING
TO SAY WHATEVER THEY CAN SO
THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
TARGET OUR KIDS. DON'T FALL FOR
THAT MEMBERS IF YOU CARE ABOUT
HEALTHCARE IN THE STATE ALIGN
YOURSELF WITH THOSE WHO ARE
FIGHTING EVERY DAY TO IMPROVE
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM NOT THE
PEOPLE WHO INFLICT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF HEALTHCARE COSTS
UPON OUR CONSTITUENTS EVERYDAY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR REGULAR
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RISE IN SUPPORT AS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE AND I WANNA TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS ONE OF
THE MORE. TROUBLING AND FRANKLY
MISLEADING A FLAT OUT UNTRUE
CLAIMS SOME OPPONENTS OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE HAVE BEEN
MAKING AND THAT IS THIS THAT
THIS BILL CRIMINALIZES TOBACCO
USE. AND WILL LEAD TO INCREASED
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE. LET ME ASSURE
YOU THAT IF IT WERE I WOULD NOT
BE A CO AUTHOR OF SB. SEVEN
NINETY. SAME WAY SIMPLY PUT SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE IN NO WAY
SHAPE OR FORM CRIMINALIZES
INDIVIDUAL USE OR INDIVIDUAL
POSSESSION OF TOBACCO PRODUCTS
WHAT THE BILL DOES DO. IS THIS
IT RESTRICTS RETAIL SALES OF
THESE PRODUCTS AND RETAIL
POSSESSION WITH THE INTENT TO
SELL. NOT INDIVIDUAL POSSESSION
NOT INDIVIDUAL USE THIS BILL
THIS BILL IN FACT IS
SPECIFICALLY CRAFTED NOT TO
CRIMINALIZE YOUTH OR
COMMUNITIES. OF COLOR I WAS
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE HISTORIC
TOBACCO REFORMS WE ENACTED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH MANY OF
YOU. THOSE REFORMS REMOVED
YOUTH PENALTIES FOR POSSESSION
AND MADE OUR TOBACCO CONTROL
LAWS MORE EQUITABLE. SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE RIGHTFULLY FOCUSES
ENFORCEMENT ON THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY NOT THEIR VICTIMS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE INCLUDING IN MY DISTRICT
ARE SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTING
ORDINANCES THAT RESTRICT
FLAVORED TOBACCO SALES WITHOUT
EVERY ANY EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THESE FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS OF
CRIMINALIZATION. AND IN
ADDITION I JUST WANT TO TOUCH
ON WHAT OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO TOUCHED ON. THAT WHILE A
BAN ON FLAVORED PRODUCTS COULD
REDUCE TOBACCO TAX REVENUE IN
THE SHORT RUN IT WOULD ALSO
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS
IN THE LONG RUN SPECIFICALLY
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS. IN
REDUCED HEALTH CARE COSTS
ANNUALLY ACCORDING TO A RECENT
SOURCE. THE ULTIMATE GOAL OF
TOBACCO TAXES IS TO GET THAT
TOBACCO TAX REVENUE TWO ZERO
THAT MEANS IT'S WORKING THAT IS
IT'S A DESIGN THAT IS ITS
INTENT BECAUSE THAT MEANS WE
HAVE DEFEATED. TOBACCO
ADDICTION AND PROTECTED THE
HEALTH AND LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SO I DON'T WANT
OUR OPPONENTS INCLUDING TOBACCO
TRY TO SCARE YOU INTO THINKING
THAT THIS BILL SOMEHOW HURTS
ONE OF THE COMMUNITIES. THEY
HAVE NEGLECTED TO TELL YOU THIS
THAT BECAUSE OF INDUSTRY
TACTICS LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS THOSE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY THE
LOT NEXT COMMUNITY THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
TOBACCO RELATED MORBIDITY AND
DEATH WE CAN NO LONGER
SUBSIDIZE THE HEALTHCARE COSTS
OF BIG TOBACCO WE WILL NOT
CRIMINALIZE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WITH THIS BILL FAR FROM
HARMING SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
WILL PROTECT. OUR COMMUNITIES
FROM THE PROVEN DANGERS OF
TOBACCO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EITHER COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU MR
BONTA MISTER FLORA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAER MEMBERS- I RISE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. AND NOT BECAUSE
I'M ACTUALLY WANT TO STAND UP
IN SUPPORT OF TOBACCO. BUT
ACTUALLY BECAUSE I JUST THINK
THIS BILL IS COMPLETELY.
HYPOCRITICAL IF WE ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT KIDS. IF THIS
WASN'T JUST AN IDEOLOGICAL
FIGHT AGAINST BIG TOBACCO. IF
WE ACTUALLY TRULY BELIEVED AND
WHAT WE'RE SAYING ABOUT OUR
YOUTH. THEN THERE WOULD BE NO
EXEMPTIONS. WE WOULD NOT BE
TAKING EXEMPTIONS FOR HOOKAH.
FOR CIGARS OVER TWELVE DOLLARS.
FOR OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN TO MAKE THIS BILL PASSED
SIMPLY SO WE COULD GET THE
VOTES AND EVEN WORSE THERE'S
ANOTHER INDUSTRY THAT YOU'RE
GETTING A FREE PASS. WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES MY DISTRICT WHAT
DISPENSARIES EVERYWHERE OUR
KIDS ARE SMOKING CANNABIS. IN
HELMET ALL DAY LONG. BUT
BECAUSE THIS NEW COOL KID ON
THE BLOCK WE LEAVE IT ALONE.
AND WE GO AFTER TOBACCO.
FRIENDS WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS
IF WE CARE ABOUT OUR KIDS. WE
MUST ADDRESS ALL OF THIS WE
MUST FIGURE OUT A WAY TO KEEP
US OUT OF OUR KIDS HANDS ON MY
PHONE RIGHT HERE HAVE A PICTURE.
OF A NERD. I GO THE LITTLE
CANDIES THE NERDS CANDY A NERD
WROTE. THERE'S EIGHT SERVINGS
IN THIS PACKAGE. FOUR HUNDRED
MILLIGRAMS OF THC IN THAT
PACKAGE FIFTY MILLIGRAMS PER
SERVING. AS I WOULD BE
UNCONSCIOUS IF I TOOK THAT. YOU
CAN'T TELL ME NO WE ARE NOT
MARKETING THIS STUFF TO OUR
KIDS SO I WOULD JUST ASK US AS
A BODY. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
SIGNIFICANT CUT SB TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR CUT. TO THE
GENERAL FUND WITH THE TOBACCO
TAX AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT
DOCTOR YOU KNOW FRIEND FROM
FRESNO IS TALKING ABOUT. AS IT
RELATES TO THIS I GET IT. IT IS
A BIG HIT. IN A PANDEMIC. THIS
MAY NOT BE THE TIME TO DO THIS.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY. FRIENDS
LET'S BE HONEST. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS BUILDING DOES NOT
LIKE BIG TOBACCO IN HOUSING FOR
A LONG TIME. BUT NOT LET'S NOT
HIDE BEHIND THE KIDS. BECAUSE
IF WE ACTUALLY CARED ABOUT THE
KIDS WE DEAL WITH ON THE OTHER
INDUSTRIES AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR MS RIVAS. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF SB SEVEN NINETY
THREE- LIKE THE MEMBERS FROM
SACRAMENTO AND FRESNO AND
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY BROUGHT UP
TO US THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
DISINFORMATION ON THIS BILL.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ALL OF US TO REFOCUS OUR
ATTENTION ON WHAT THE BILL
ACTUALLY DOES AND THAT IS
PROTECT OUR KIDS I TRUST THE
RECORD OF THE HUNDREDS OF YOUTH
ADVOCATES AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CHAMPIONS THAT ARE BEHIND THIS
BILL I STRONGLY URGE AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
OF US MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB
SEVEN NINETY THREE. I RISE AS A
MOM WHO HAS SEEN MY TWELVE YEAR
OLD MY TWELVE YEAR OLD IN
SEVENTH GRADE OFFERED FLAVORED
VAPING PRODUCTS IN THE BATHROOM
BY THE COOL KIDS. AND I ALSO
RISE AS AS THE NIECE OF MY
UNCLE MURPHY WHO FIRST BECAME
HOOKED ON CIGARETTES WHEN HE
WAS AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
SOLDIER IN VIETNAM AND HE
BECAME A PACK A DAY SMOKER.
AFTER A PAINFUL HEART WRENCHING
AND ULTIMATELY UNSUCCESSFUL
BATTLE WITH LUNG CANCER HE DIED
TOO YOUNG AT THE AGE OF FIFTY
THREE HE WAS LIKE A FATHER TO
ME AND I WAS BY HIS BEDSIDE IN
THE HOSPITAL AT THE TIME. AND
I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU SEEN WHAT
HE WENT THROUGH. MY KIDS
DESERVE BETTER THAN THAT AND
YOUR KIDS DESERVE BETTER THAN
THAT AND ALL CALIFORNIA KIDS
DESERVE A BETTER LIFE THAN NOT
AND THIS BILL. IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO MAKE THAT
A REALITY THIS ISN'T ABOUT NOT
LIKING BIG TOBACCO ARE NOT
LIKING ANYBODY ELSE. THIS IS
ABOUT ELEVEN CALIFORNIA KIDS IN
DOING WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA KIDS SO I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK WAS
FISHING NORRIS. IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. DR WEBER. IS TO
GET RECOGNITION DR WEBER YES MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE
THREE AND I RISE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE GIVEN ALL THE
REASONS WHY WE SHOULD BE
STANDING FOR THIS CALL US
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF TOBACCO AND MOST OF
OUR LOVED ONES WHO HAVE PASSED
AWAY AND I'VE HAD A LOT WHO
HAVE. ALWAYS TELL ME THAT THEY
BEGAN AS A KID. THEY BEGAN WHEN
THEY WERE YOUNG. AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT THEY STRUGGLED
WITH THEIR WHOLE LIFE AND
ACTUALLY GAVE THEIR LIFE AS A
RESULT OF IT SO WE CAN SIT HERE
AND PRETEND THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT OTHER ISSUES
AFFECTING YOUNG PEOPLE AND IT'S
ALWAYS AMAZING TO ME WITH ALL
THE LEGISLATION THAT I PUT
FORTH IS ALWAYS ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT WE SHOULD BE ADDRESSING
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE ISSUE
THAT IS BEFORE US. SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO REALIZE THAT
YES THIS WORLD IS FILLED WITH
ISSUES AND AS WE IF WE'RE GOING
TO DEAL WITH THEM WE DEAL WITH
THEM ONE AT A TIME AND IT'S NOT
EASY TO DEAL WITH ANY OF THESE
ISSUES BUT WE HAVE TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AS IT FACES
US. AND THIS IS GROWING THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT TOBACCO WAS
LOSING YOUNG PEOPLE BECAUSE WHY
WOULD IT HAVE A CAMPAIGN ON HOW
UGLY TOBACCO WAS AND HOW PEOPLE
WHO LOOK AFTER THEY SMOKED AND
HOW THEY LOOK WITHOUT THEIR
LUNGS AND WITHOUT THEIR WITHOUT
THEIR THROATS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS AND SO AS A RESULT WE
WOULD NOT FIND THE INDUSTRY
TRYING TO ATTRACT THEM TO OTHER
THINGS. YOU CAN'T TELL ME THAT
THE FLAVORED TOBACCO IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS ATTRACTIVE TO
YOUNG PEOPLE NOT THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY ADDICTED BUT IT
PROVIDES A WAY TO DIP OF
INSTANCE I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN NINE THREE. BUT I ALSO
RISE AS A PERSON WHO HAS SPENT
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS OF HER
LIFE LEARNING AND TEACHING
AFRICAN AMERICAN HISTORY. AND I
AM INSULTED. IN THAT THE
TOBACCO. WOULD MAKE. AN EFFORT
TO A BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
COUPLE. THE LATEST. IS A PART
OF AFTER AMERICAN. AND THAT'S
WHAT'S BEING STATED AND THAT
THIS IS A DISCRIMINATORY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AGAINST BLACK
PEOPLE. AND SO I'VE HAD PEOPLE
CALLING ME SAYING THIS IS
UNFAIR TO US IF IT'S SOMEONE
WANTS TO SAVE US AND OUR
CHILDREN AND FINALLY FINALLY
FOCUS UPON AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND YOU CONSIDER THAT
DISCRIMINATORY. IN THAT CASE
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN OPPOSED TO
SLAVERY ECAUSE ACTUALLY WAS
DISCRIMINATORY SINCE WE WERE
THE ONLY ONES IN SLAVES IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND YET YOU DECIDED
THAT IT WAS WORTH THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD GET RID OF
BECAUSE IT IS UNDESIRABLE AND
IT'S THERE'S NO BENEFITS. WHEN
I LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
TOBACCO IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
IT IS NOT A CULTURALY BACKED
THERE'S NOTHING ABOUT IT THAT I
HAVE READ ALL THE BOOKS THAT
I'VE STUDIED ALL THE RESEARCH
WE'VE DONE THIS AS BLACK PEOPLE
ARE MORE INTERESTED IN MID TO
LATE A CIGARETTE AND SOMEHOW I
KNOW THAT IT REPRESENTS THEIR
CULTURE. IT REPRESENTS WHO THEY
ARE. IT BUILDS UP THEIR VALUE
SYSTEM. IT GIVES THEM AN
IDENTITY AYE WE INSANE. NO THIS
IS WHAT WE USED TO CALL
WATERMELON POLITICS. AND IF
YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR%
COMMUNITY WHEN I WAS A KID IN
THE PROJECT TO WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE SOUTH. POLITICIANS AND
OTHERS WOULD COME TO OUR
COMMUNITY WHAT THE WHAT WHAT I
CAN FOR THE WATERMELON. AND
PASS THEM OUT AND TALKING TO
GET VOTES AND GET SUPPORT
WATERMELON POLITICS BUT YOU
NEVER SEE AGAIN. THIS IS ONE OF
THE MOST RACIST THING TO EVER
TALK ABOUT THAT BLACK PEOPLE
SOMEHOW DOUBLE LOVE MID TO LATE
CIGARETTES. AND IT'S A PART OF
OUR CULTURE AND IT'S GOING TO
DEMONISE US IT'S GOING TO HURT
OUR GRANDMOTHERS AND OLDER
PEOPLE WHO ARE ADDICTED TO
MIDDLE LATEST. I AM. AS A
SCHOLAR AS A MEMBER OF THIS
HOUSE AS A PERSONAL JUST
REQUIRED ETHNIC STUDIES BUT
EVERY CSU GRADUATE IN THE
STATE. THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS NOT
BEEN ONE MINUTE TALKING ABOUT
AFRICAN AMERICAN CULTURE WOULD
HAVE THE AUDACITY. TO TELL ME
THAT THIS IS BLACK. THAT IS
WHAT BLACK ARE ABOUT. NO THIS
IS WHAT RACIST ABOUT ONE OF MY
A DOLLAR ON BLUE AND POOR KIDS.
A YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS
IS WHAT THIS ISAND WE SHOULD
NOT CONFUSE IT SO IF YOU THINK
YOU'RE VOTING TO HELP BLACK
PEOPLE. DON'T DO THAT. VOTE
AGAINST A VOTE FOR THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A RACE
ISSUE. THIS IS AN ECONOMIC
ISSUE THAT HAS ALWAYS HELPED
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND USE THEM
FOR THE BENEFIT. SO I'M OUTRAGE
AS A MEMBER OF THIS HOUSEHOLD
WILL SUPPORT HIM I'LL REYES AS
A SCHOLAR THAT THEY WOULD USE
THIS TO TRY TO PRETEND THAT
THEY ARE HELPING BLACK PEOPLE
PROMOTING OUR CULTURE AND THEN
USE OUR FRIENDS AND OUR
MINISTERS AND OTHERS TO MAKE US
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S SOME
DISCRIMINATION IN THIS. I SAID
IF THEY ARE DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST ASSIST TIME HALLELUJAH
BECAUSE OF THE DISCRIMINATION.
AND MAYBE WE'LL GET TO THE
OTHERS LATER ON AT THE HOOKAH
LOUNGES AND OTHER PLACES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
PROTECTED ALSO. SOMEONE
ENCOURAGED YOU TO BOTH SB SEVEN
NINE THREE. AS A GOOD BILL.
THAT WILL BEGIN TO DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE AND PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN FROM WHAT WE SEE IS
COMING. WHICH IS A HORRIBLE
HABIT. THAT WOULD DEVASTATE THE
LIVES AND TAKE THE BEST OF
THEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU DR WEBER. MS GONZALEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. IT'S ALWAYS
DIFFICULT TO MAKE THE CHOICE
WHETHER TO SPEAK AFTER DOCTOR
WEBER I'M SORRY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO- BUT I'VE CHOSEN
TO FOR VERY PERSONAL REASONS.
MY MOM STARTED SMOKING WHEN SHE
WAS SIXTEEN. A LOT OF YOU KNOW
I LOST HER VERY EARLY SHE ENDED
UP WITH BREAST CANCER AT FORTY
TWO. AND THEN AFTER REMISSION
IT CAME BACK AS LUNG CANCER.
SHE DIED OF LUNG CANCER AT
SIXTY TWO. AND THE ONLY THING
SHE ASKED ME IS TO MAKE SURE MY
KIDS NEVER SMOKED. IT SEEMS
LIKE SUCH A SIMPLE IDEA ISSUE
WITH ON HER DEATH BED BE SURE
MY KIDS DON'T SMOKE SMOKING IS
GROSS THEY HEARD FROM EVERYBODY
FROM TE TIME THAT THEY WERE
BORN SHOULD BE EASY. BUT WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SAID WHEN YOU END UP HAVING AN
ESPECIALLY YOUNG BOYS BUT ALL
KIDS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL. YOU REALIZE JUST HOW
MANY KIDS ARE DOING BETH. JUST
HOW AVAILABLE THESE VAPING
PRODUCTS ARE AND GUESS WHAT.
IT'S NOT SO GROSS IT DOESN'T
SMELL SO GROSS IT DOESN'T TASTE
SO GROSS. SO THE PARENT. YOU
SPEND YOUR TIME TRYING TO
EXPLAIN TO YOUR KID WHY
SOMETHING THAT SOCIETY IS
SAYING THIS IS MUCH SAFER THAN
SMOKING THIS IS THIS IS NOT THE
SAME. YOU TRY TO. CONVINCE THEM
THAT NOW GETTING HOOKED ON
NICOTINE IS THE SAME. YOU'RE
SETTING YOURSELF. UP FOR A
LIFETIME OF DISEASE. I WISH
EVERYBODY IN THIS CHAMBER. HAD
A MIDDLE SCHOOL OR HIGH SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN. TO JUST KNOW
EXACTLY HOW PREVALENT THIS IS.
I DIDN'T GET THE A THE PUSH IN
MY DISTRICT ABOUT THIS. BEING
SOMEHOW DISCRIMINATORY AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS. I GOTTA PUSH
ABOUT BEING DISCRIMINATORY
AGAINST POOR PEOPLE. AND NOT TO
IS OFFENSIVE. BECAUSE I AGREED
WITH MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE EXCEPTIONS
IN THIS SHOULDN'T EXIST I THINK
WE SHOULD DO OUR BEST TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE COVERING ALL TOBACCO.
BUT WHAT'S DISCRIMINATORY
AGAINST POOR PEOPLE IS GETTING
THEM HOOKED. ON SMOKING AND NOT
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE. NOT
PROVIDING THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THEY KNOW WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THEM ESPECIALLY
POOR KIDS. SO I'D BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS I
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT ATTRACTING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO ANY KIND OF
SMOKING OR DRUGS. BUT YOU DON'T
SAY NO TO SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO ACTUALLY HELP TODAY IN
ORDER FOR A PERFECT SOLUTION IN
THE FUTURE. YOU DO WHAT YOU
CAN'T. WE WILL SAVE LIVES BY
PASSING THAT THAT WE KNOW. I
DON'T KNOW ALL THE STATISTICS
ARE THE HEALTH REASONS AND I'LL
LEAVE THAT TO THE PEOPLE WORK
ON THIS. I JUST KNOW AS A
PARENT. A. B. INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL TO NOT HAVE PRODUCTS
OUT THERE THAT ARE TRACTIVE IN
NOT GROSS FOR OUR CHILDREN. I
THINK THIS GETS US PARTIALLY
THERE. I'M PROUD TO BE A JOINT
AUTHORS SB SEVEN NINETY THREE
AND I HOPE THAT WE GET A LOT OF
VOTES TODAY. THANK YOU MS
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MEMBERS
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS AFTER
READING THE BILL IT TOOK ME
ABOUT TWO SECONDS TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
MORALLY- AFTER I SAW THE
ADVERTISEMENTS. FROM THE
OPPONENTS I FELT LIKE I WAS TWO
SECONDS TOO LONG I'M PROUD TO
BE A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. EVERY PERSON IN
THIS ROOM KNOWS THE DAMAGE THAT
TOBACCO USE DOES TO OUR BODIES.
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND IT IS CHILDREN
WHO ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
ITS DEVASTATING EFFECTS.
THEY'RE GROWING BRAINS AND
LUNGS CAN SUFFER LIFELONG
DAMAGE. DESPITE THIS THE
AVERAGE AGE OF A NEW SMOKER IS
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD. 90% OF
SMOKERS START BEFORE THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN. IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE RAISE THE SMOKING
AGE TO TWENTY ONE TO HELP TO
PREVENT YOUNG PEOPLE FROM BEING
ADDICTED AT SUCH AN EARLY AGE.
BUT OUR WORK IS NOT YET OVER.
BIG TOBACCO HAS FOUND AN EVEN
MORE INSIDIOUS WAY TOOK OUR
KIDS. FLAVORS LIKE COTTON CANDY
AND GUMMY BEARS MAKE THIS
POISON TASTE LIKE CANDY. THESE
FLAVORS ARE MARKETED FOR KIDS
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR TO ENSURE
TOBACCO COMPANIES HAVE A
CLIENTELE ON THE HOOK FOR LIFE.
THIS BILL PREVENTS RETAILERS
FROM SELLING THE VAST MAJORITY
OF FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
PRODUCTS WE KNOW KIDS ARE USING
EVERY DAY. LET'S CONTINUE THE
IMPORTANT WORK WE STARTED
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM A
LIFETIME OF ADDICTION AND
DAMAGE SHALL I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB SEVEN NINE THREE.
DAMOS SPEAKER DR WOULD YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. TO ME THE BILL IS
VERY SIMPLE OF ODS IS TO VOTE
TO HELP PROTECT OUR CHILDREN.
ABOUT NO IT'S TO HELP REPORT
PROTECT BIG TOBACCO THE CHOICE
IS YOURS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. AND WITHOUT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT HIGHS FIFTY KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TAKING UP AMENDMENTS.
THIS IS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. WE ARE GOING TO
WITHOUT OBJECTION TAKE A FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY S. B. ONE THIRTY TWO FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
OPERATE WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY TWO WITH THE
MINUTES BY SOME WOMEN MARK
STONE. MR STONE ON THE MEN'S.
MR HAMMOND SEGMENTS DOWN THE
STRETCH DOWN ON THE MEN'S YOU
MAY CONTINUE. RECESSION BETWEEN
CDC ARE THE AUTHOR I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT THE BILL BE SENT OUT TO
PRINT AND PUT BACK ON THE FIVE.
THANK YOU MISPRONOUNCING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YES SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO
PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY FOUR. THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR S. B. NINE
FIFTEEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITH THE
MOMENT. THIS IS. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR S. B.
NINE FIFTEEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM READY FOR SB
NINE FIFTEEN. MR KILEY. YOU MAY
OPEN ON YOUR AMENDMENTS CORKERY.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTEEN WITH A
MINUTES BY SOME MEMBER KILEY
SAID TO. MR KILEY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A VERY
MODEST AMENDMENT TO ASK FOLKS
KNOW THERE'S A LARGE DEBATE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW OVER THE
STATUS OF RIDE SHARE DRIVERS
AND THAT IS OUTSIDE OF THE
CONTROL OF OUR LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW. HOWEVER WHAT WAS IS
WITHIN OUR CONTROL AND WHAT IS
NOT GOING TO BE DECIDED ON ANY
UPCOMING ELECTION IS THE STATUS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND HUNDREDS OF
OTHER PROFESSIONS. AND SO THIS
AMENDMENT IS VERY MODEST ALL IT
WOULD DO IS GIVE FOLKS IN THESE
HUNDRED PROFESSIONS WHO HAVE
BEEN PREVENT PROHIBITED FROM
WORKING BY LAST YEAR'S ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BACK TO WORK AT A TIME WHEN
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS. ARE OUT
OF WORK AND LOOKING FOR A WAY
TO GET BY AND SO I PLEASE ASK
FOR AN IBM. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I MOVED AWAY THE
MINUTES ON THE TABLE. MR
COLORADO MOVING TO LAY THE
MEMBERS ON THE TABLE SECONDED
BY MR BONTA. MEMBERS THIS IS A%
PROCEDURAL MISSED FOR YOUR
RECOGNIZE JUST WANNA CONFIRM
RELATED IMAGE ON THE TABLE. MR
KILEY IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER CALDERON ASKING FOR NO
VOTE. AGAINST THE AMENDMENTS
CORRECT. MISTER CALDERON IS
MOVING TO NAY THE MEMBERS ON
THE TABLE SO THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE ON LAYING THE
MAN'S. MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING IN THE AFFIRMATIVE.
MEMBERS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
BEFORE THE BODY. MISTER FLORIO
RECOGNIZED SO WE JUST WANNA
MAKE A CLARIFICATION WE'RE
GOING TO. TAKE A VOTE TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT OKAY.
MISTER CALDERON FOR A PURPOSE
FOR CLEAR THEIR FURTHER
CLARIFICATION THIS VOTE IS ON A
PROCEDURAL MOTION NOT ON THE
SET OF AMENDMENTS NOR ON THE
BILL THIS IS A VOTE STRICTLY ON
THE PROCEDURAL MOTION TO LAY
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
YOUR CORRECTNESS CALDERON. THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE FOR THE
BODY. MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING%
FOR AN AYE VOTE MR KILEY IS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE FOR
COLLATERAL. CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AYE VOTES THIS IS TOO LATE.
THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
THIS REQUIRES A MAJORITY
PRESENT AND VOTING THAT IS THE
THRESHOLD. MISTER CALDERON
CESSFORD I'VE OF. MR KILEY AND
NOW. MAJORITY PRESIDENT VOTING
IS THE THRESHOLD. CLARK WELL.
CULTURAL CALVET EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS FIFTEEN THE MEMBERS ARE
LAID ON THE TABLE. THIS IS
AGAIN FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR SB
NINE FIFTEEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENT CLERK
WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTEEN WITH A
MINUTES BY SUMMARILY MON SAT
ONE MISS LIMóN ON THE MEMONS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBER THE
AMENDMENTS TO SP NINE FIFTEEN
ARE CLEAR FIND IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I THINK IT WAS AROUND
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS SET OF AMENDMENTS AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT. THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. AND BACK ON
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
FIVE. SB. NINE FORTY. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
SEPARATELY THE MENACE SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY WITH A MINUTES
BY SIMPLY MEMBER KALRA MISTER
KALRA NAME EVENTS THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY
PERCENT NON SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS TO SP NINE FORTY THE
BILL TO AUTHORIZE THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE TO MAKE SMART IS
OWNING UP DAYS OF A PROTECT
OPEN SPACE. AND REDUCE SPRAWL.
IT MEMBERS MAKE THE BILLS ONLY
REQUIREMENTS ALIGNED WITH SB
THREE THIRTY AND PLACE
ADDITIONAL GUARDRAILS ON THE
DOWN ZONING RESTRICTIONS. TO
FURTHER ENSURE THE BILL
MAINTAINS THE CITY'S OVERALL
HOUSING CAPACITY. RESPECT
REQUEST AYE VOTE ON AMENDMENTS
TO SP NINE FORTY. THINGS KALRA
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. JOSE NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT
THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS
AS PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN. SB NINE OH FIVE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
CORKERY WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE
BILL NINE OH FIVE THE MINUTES
TO THE BANANA FIBER THE MEMBERS
BY SOME REMEMBER KILEY SET TO.
YEAH AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
I'M EIGHTY SEVEN SB NINE OH
FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
MEMIKIRKAN WITH THE MAN SENATE
NINE OH FIVE THE MINUTES BY
SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ AT ONE.
GONZALEZ ON THE MINUTES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THESE
AMENDMENTS MAKE CHANGES TO
RESOLVE HAPPENING CHAPTER IN
THE CONFLICTS I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANKS GONZALEZ SENIOR
DISCUSS HER DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
MAY TAKEA VOICE VOTE ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY
NAY THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE. NOW
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO. SB THIRTEEN FORTY
NINE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT CIRCLE REMEMBER
CYNICAL THIRTEEN FORTY NINE OF
THE MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
GRAYSON. MR GRAYSON ON THE
MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ALIGN THE LANGUAGE
TO THE LANGUAGE OF AB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE WHICH WAS PASSED
OFF THE FLOOR AND WAS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR LAST YEAR. AN
EXACT EXEMPTS SPECIAL
TRANSPORTATION TAXES FROM THE
STATUTORY 2% CAP ON SALES AND
YOU STILL END USE TAXES IN OUR
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THINGS GRAYSON SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT. IN ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE WERE TO GO BACK AND
TAKE UP AMENDMENTS ON AN ITEM
THAT WAS ON SECOND READING THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. S. B.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS READ WITH
AMANDA SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN WITH A MEMBER BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD. DOCTOR WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THESE AMENDMENTS TO TWO
PRIMARY THINGS THEY ADDRESS NON
PHYSICIAN PROVIDERS BY REMOVING
NON PHYSICIAN PROVIDERS SUCH AS
OPTOMETRISTS AND DENTISTS FROM
THE DEFINITION PROVIDER. AND
NUMBER TWO THEY AMEND THE
DEFINITION OF ACQUISITION THE
CLARIFIES THE DEFINITION OF
ACQUISITION TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT WITH THE TYPES OF
ACQUISITIONS HAD ALREADY COME
UNDER. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
REVIEW AN EXISTING LAW FOR
NONPROFITS AND HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES HAS BESET BY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
ACT WHAT. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE MEMONS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT BILLS OUT
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE.
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER
TAKING UP AMENDMENTS THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY SIX. SB TEN
SEVENTY NINE. CORP WILL READ
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME IMMIGRATION MISTER GRAYSON
ON THE MAMMOTHS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER OF THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
TECHNICAL CHANGES REQUESTED BY
THE TRUSTEES AND ADDRESS
CHAPLAIN- CHAPTER IN CONFLICTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I THINK
IT WAS GRAYSON. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
HEARD ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
I A POST SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY
SEVEN. SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
PARKER READ WITH A MEASURE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
WITH A MINUTES BY SOME REMEMBER
ALMOST MR RAMASAMY MEMONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
AMENDMENT AMENDMENT SIMPLY
RESOLVE CHAPTER IN ISSUES WITH
S. B. TEN SEVENTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL. RAMOS RAMOS C.
NOTIFICATION AVE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE HI. OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT HE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS AT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FIVE.
MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE. WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH FILE ITEM EIGHTY. PASS AND
RETAIN. FILE ITEM A. ONE
ACTUALLY WE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT
TWO TO THAT ITEM. THAT'S FIVE
EIGHTY ONE PASS A RETAINER FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY TWO. READYTO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE. SB
ONE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE MINUTES
CAM LAGER. IF YOU WISH THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE SB ONE
FIFTY EIGHT CORPORATE SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
ALLEN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS THE COLOR OF YOUR TO
SEE THEIR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MS KAMLAGER. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I.
READ THE RESENT THEM SB ONE
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH IS A SIMPLE
TECHNICAL CLEAN A BILL THAT
CLARIFIES THAT NO PARTY.
PREFERENCE VOTERS CAN BE
INCLUDED ON THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
PERSONAL TO VOTER REGISTRATIONS
IN THE COUNTY THE L. A. COUNTY
INDEPENDENT REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WITH THE GOAL OF PROVIDING. A
SIMILAR PUBLIC PROCESS AS WAS
PROVIDED BY THE CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. THIS
INCLUDES SELECTING FOURTEEN
COMMISSIONERS THAT ARE
REFLECTIVE OF THE POLITICAL
PARTY PREFERENCES AND THE
COUNTY HOWEVER NO IN P. P.'S
ARE NOT CONSIDERED. HOWEVER
NPP'S ARE NOT CONSIDERED A
POLITICAL PARTY ALTHOUGH THEY
MAKE UP ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
VOTERS OR 26% OF REGISTERED
VOTERS IN L. A. COUNTY. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THAT THE
COMMISSION BE CREATED BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO ON URGENCY CLAUSE IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THIS
CLARIFICATION AS CODIFIED. WITH
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE COUNTY TO
INCLUDE IN P. P. VOTERS IN THE
COMMISSION OUR SELECTION
PROCESS THIS IS A TECHNICAL
BILL BUT IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THE INDEPENDENT
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION
REPRESENTS. THE POLITICAL
DIVERSITY OF L. A. COUNTY
VOTERS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. I THINK IT WAS KAMLAGER
MR GALLAGHER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
YEAH WE CONSIDER THIS BILL IN
THE ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE I THINK THIS IS
EXHIBIT A OF WHY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE.
CONTROLLING LOCALS- ELECTIONS
DECISIONS THAT COUNTY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT ON THEIR OWN WE
GOT IN THAT BUSINESS TWO YEARS
AGO WE DECIDED TO CREATE THIS
REDISTRICTING. COMMISSION FOR
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
GUESS WHAT WE MESSED IT UP AND
NOW WE GOT TO FIX IT BY
ALLOWING. AFTER NO PARTY
PREFERENCE VOTERS. TO BE
ALLOWED TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION AGAIN
WE SHOULD BE LEAVING THIS I'M
FINE WITH SUPPORTING THIS
CHANGE. BUT IT I THINK AGAIN
JUST SHOWS THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THIS IS IN OUR ROLE
THEY SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
COUNTIES TO DECIDE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THE REDISTRICTING.
HOW THEY'RE GONNA HAVE THEIR
PROCESSES FOR THEIR LOCAL
ELECTIONS- AND SO I THINK WE
NEED TO BE AGAIN VERY
THOUGHTFUL. IN HOW WE GO ABOUT
POLICY IN THIS BUILDING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MS KAMLAGER YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU I.
RESPECT THE COMMENTS OF- MY
COLLEAGUE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. WITHOUT
CRITICAL OF THE ROLE. WE DESIRE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. MY ON. PERHAPS THIS
TAKES THIRTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS KAMLAGER
MOVES A CALL.
THE RESERVATION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE AHEAD IN
THE FILE TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT. F. I. EIGHTY EIGHT S. B.
NINE SEVENTY. CORPORATE SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTY BY SENATOR
UMBERG AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS. MR
BERMAN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SB NINE SEVENTY JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY SENATOR ON BERGEN
MYSELF. AND PRINCIPALLY CO
AUTHORED BY BOTH THE PRO TEM IN
THE SPEAKER TO ENSURE THAT OUR
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY ELECTIONS
WILL REMAIN IN JUNE. THAT'S
RIGHT I THINK THIS BILL IS THE
ONLY THING THE SPEAKER IN PRO
TEM ARE IN AGREEMENT ON RIGHT
NOW. CALIFORNIA IS
TRADITIONALLY HELD ITS PRIMARY
ELECTIONS IN JUNE. WITH THE
ONLY EXCEPTIONS OCCURRING
BECAUSE OF A DESIRE TO HAVE A
GREATER SAY IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINATING PROCESS. THIS BILL
WILL NOT CHANGE THE DATE OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES THEY
WILL REMAIN IN MARCH. HOWEVER
THERE ARE TWO MAIN REASONS TO
MOVE THE GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY
BACK TO JUNE. IN A DECISION
ISSUED LAST MONTH THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT PUSHED
BACK THE DEADLINE FOR THE
CITIZENS REDISTRICTING. TO
ADOPT ASSEMBLY SENATE
CONGRESSIONAL AND BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION DISTRICTS FROM
AUGUST FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO DECEMBER FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DEADLINE FOR ADOPTING NEW
DISTRICT LINES IS INCOMPATIBLE
WITH THE MARCH PRIMARY ELECTION
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. IN FACT
UNDER CURRENT LAW CANDIDATE
FILING FOR A MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO PRIMARY ELECTION
WOULD END. FIVE DAYS BEFORE THE
DEADLINE FOR THE REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION TO ADOPT NEW
DISTRICT LINES. THE OTHER
REASON IS TO REDUCE THE LENGTH
OF THE GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION
CYCLE. SINCE NINETEEN FORTY SIX
WITH THE LONE EXCEPTION OF THE
TWO THOUSAND TWO ELECTION. THE
STATEWIDE PRIMARY ELECTION
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION YEAS
HAS BEEN HELD IN JUNE. A MARCH
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY RESULT IN
AN UNNECESSARILY ELONGATED
ELECTION CYCLE WITH AN EIGHT
MONTH GAP BETWEEN THE PRIMARY
AND THE GENERAL ELECTION.
MOVING THE PRIMARY TO JUNE
WOULD SHORTEN THE ELECTION
SEASON TO A MUCH MORE
REASONABLE FIVE MONTHS. SB NINE
SEVENTY IS SUPPORTED BY COMMON
CAUSE THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE AND HAS ZERO
OPPOSITION. THERE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE AS A CONSENT ITEM
I THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN. MR GALLAGHER YOUR- YES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
IS ELECTIONS A REDISTRICTING
DAY APPARENTLY- SO LOOK MEMBERS.
SORRY LAST YEAR RIGHT WE VOTED.
TO MAKE OUR PRIMARY BE IN MARCH.
THIS WAS THE SECOND TIME THAT
WE HAD DONE THIS- WE DID IT
BACK IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
AND THE WHOLE PURPOSE WAS HEY
LET'S HAVE A PRIMARY MARCH TO
BE RELEVANT. IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES I DIDN'T
REALLY WORK THEN. AND IT DIDN'T
WORK THIS LAST TIME REALLY
EITHER. BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
I THINK OUR VOTERS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS EXPECT US TO MAKE
A DECISION. AND STICK WITH IT
AND BE CONSISTENT. I VOTED FOR
THAT LEGISLATION. BY MISTER
SPEAKER THIS MISTER SPEAKER-
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
CREATE THE PRIMARY MAKE IT IN
MARCH AND LET'S JUST KEEP IT IN
MARCH SO THAT EVERYBODY KNOWS
AND VOTERS CAN GET COMFORTABLE
WITH THE FACT THAT THEY WILL BE
PRIMARIES IN MARCH AND STAY
WITH IT BUT IF WE KEEP MOVING
BACK AND FORTH ALL WE'RE DOING
IS CONFUSING VOTERS. SO NOW
WE'RE GONNA GO TO WELL WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A PRIMARY IN MARCH
IN PRESIDENTIAL YEARS BUT THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE AN IN JUNE.
IN NON PRESIDENTIAL YEARS- NONE
OF THIS I THINK MAKES MUCH
SENSE AT ALL WE EITHER HAVE IT
IN JUNE WE HAVE IT IN MARCH.
LET'S MAKE UP OUR MIND AND
STICK WITH IT. I URGE A NO VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. WE DECIDED AS
A BODY TO MOVE IT TO MARCH JUST
LAST YEAR. AND NOW WERE
CHANGING IT AGAIN. I MEAN FOR
EVERYBODY'S SAKE LET'S STICK
WITH SOMETHING AND STOP
CHANGING ARE RULES. WITH EVERY
NEW ELECTION CYCLE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER SEEN
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. MR BERMAN. YOU MAY CLOSE
WE WISH. THANK YOU ARE MUCH
JUST TO BE CLEAR A NO VOTE
WOULD MEAN THAT. THE PRIMARY
THE CANDIDATE FILING FOR THE
PRIMARY WOULD END FIVE DAYS
BEFORE THE- DISTRICT MAPS WILL
COME OUT. THAT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE A GOOD PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THE BIGGEST BERMAN AND WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE SERVER. WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER AS FIFTY KNOWS
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES. WHAT
A PASS RETAIN UP OUT OF EIGHTY
NINE WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NINETY. THIS IS
SENATE BILL. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. QUICKLY SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MINING INOCULATED TO EMPLOYMENT
MIS READ US YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR MONEY IN THIS MEASURE
UPDATES EXISTING LAW TO ALLOW
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER TO
PROVIDE NO COST REPRESENTATION
TO CLAIMANTS IN ARBITRATION
PROCEEDINGS CURRENTLY EMPLOYEES
SUBJECT TO MANDATORY
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS MAY BE
BARRED FROM USING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S INFORMAL WAGE
CLAIM PROCESS AND ARE PREVENTED
FROM BEING REPRESENTED AND
FURTHER JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS.
BY ALLOWING THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO REPRESENT A
WAGE CLAIM IN IN AN ARBITRAL
FORUM SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WILL GIVE WORKERS A FIGHTING
CHANCE I WILL BE A STEP TOWARDS
BALANCING THE POWER AND
EMPLOYMENT ARBITRATION
PROCEEDINGS THIS BILL NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK IS REVERSED SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
A COUPLE OF NARAL. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
A VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLE TALBERT EYES FORTY TWO. NO
STATE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE
ARE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM NINETY
TWO THIS BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NINETY THREE SB. EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO. QUICKLY SENATE BILL EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
INSURANCE. DR WHICH- THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS YEAR
ROUND FIRE SEASONS IN THE
DEVASTATING FIRES OF RECENT
YEARS AND THIS YEAR HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATIONS TO INCREASE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS REGARDING
PROPERTY INSURANCE. SB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS AND PROTECTIONS
FOR VICTIMS OF INSURED LOSSES
AFTER DECLARE DISASTERS IN
SEVERAL IMPORTANT WAYS. IT
PROVIDES A SIXTY DAY GRACE
PERIOD FOR PREMIUM PAYMENT
REQUIRES AN ADVANCE OF FOUR
MONTHS ADDITIONAL LIVING
EXPENSES IF THE CLAIM IS
RELATED TO A DECLARED
EMERGENCY. IT ALLOWS ADDITIONAL
LIVING EXPENSES WHEN THE HOME
IS RENDERED UNINHABITABLE AS A
RESULT OF A COVERED PERIL.
INTERPRETED PROHIBITS THE
DEDUCTION OF LAND VALUE IF THE
POLICY HOLDER PURCHASE A
REPLACEMENT AT ANOTHER LOCATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
FORMER. A DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ALL THE TIME BUT I
WAS FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEMS NINETY FOUR NINETY
FIVE WE'VE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEMS NINETY SIX AND NINETY
SEVEN. JUST FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT SB. ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN.
CORKERY SENATE BILL ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY SIT AROUND FOR
ANOTHER SNACK RELATED. MS REYES.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN IS THE FIRST
IN THE NATION BILL THAT
REQUIRES LANDLORDS TO MANAGE
SUBSIDIZED MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES TO OFFER
THEIR TENANTS THE OPTION OF
HAVING THEIR RENT PAYMENTS
REPORTED TO A MAJOR CREDIT
BUREAU. THE BILL HAS A SIMPLE
GOAL PROVIDE RENTERS ARE WAY TO
ESTABLISH OR IMPROVE THEIR
CREDIT SCORES THROUGH THE
PAYMENT OF RENT. BY FOCUSING ON
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING THE BILL IS
TAILORED TO THOSE TENANTS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE GREATEST
BENEFIT FROM ITS PROVISIONS. WE
ALL KNOW THE NEGATIVE CREDIT
ACCOUNT CONSEQUENCES WHEN
PEOPLE FAIL TO PAY THEIR RENT.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY TENANTS
WHO REGULARLY PAY THEIR RENT
SHOULDN'T RECEIVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT ON THEIR CREDIT SCORE
FOR DOING SO. ESPECIALLY NOW
WHAT MANY PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
ECONOMICALLY DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC THIS BILL OFFERS A
SIMPLE EFFECTIVE SOLUTION FOR
HELPING PEOPLE IMPROVE THEIR
FINANCIAL WELL BEING. SB ELEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN IS CO SPONSORED BY
THE CREDIT THE BUILDER'S
ALLIANCE MISSION ASSET FUND AND
PROSPERITY NOW AND IS SUPPORTED
BY OVER TWO DOZEN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS FOCUSED ON ASSET
BUILDING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS REYES C. NOTIFICATION OF A-
CORPORAL. IT IS HARD TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL
CLOSE ROSADA. I FORTY TWO NO
SIX. THE MEASURE PASSES.
ASCERTAIN OUR FILE ITEMS NINETY
NINE AND ONE HUNDRED. AS WELL
AS- ONE A ONE AND ONE OF TO
THIS BRINGS US FILE ITEM ONE OF
THREE. SB TWELVE NINETY CORKERY
SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY BY
SENATOR ANOTHER SNACK RELATING
TO JUVENILES MISTER DAVID CHIU
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
TWELVE NINETY THIS BILL WILL
END THE HARMFUL AND COSTLY
COLLECTION OF JUVENILE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES CHARGED TO
YOUTH TWENTY ONE UNDER IN OUR
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEMS PARKING FEES FROM
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAS BEEN AGGRESSIVE
AND FINANCIALLY UNSOUND WAY FOR
GOVERNMENT TO FUND PUBLIC
SERVICES. RESEARCHERS FOUND THE
JUVENILE FEES UNDERMINE
REHABILITATION AND INCREASE
RECIDIVISM THIS BILL MAKE ALL
PREVIOUSLY ASSESSED FEES ON
ENFORCEABLE AND COLLECTIBLE AND
WILL VACATE PREVIOUS COURT
JUDGMENTS STIPULATE AGREEMENTS
AND OTHER INSTRUMENTS IMPOSING
SUCH FEES THISBILLS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND WITH THAT I'D
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THINGS
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL OVER THERE ALL.
MEMBERS IT IS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE TYLER I
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THERE
IS A AN ADDITIONAL ITEM OF
BUSINESS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
BE TAKING UP AND LATER IN THE
HOUR. BASED ON THE SEVENTY TWO
HOUR RULE. WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO A IBM'S ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY AT THIS TIME. AS SUCH
MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES WHO WILL BE A
TURNING. IN THE MEMORY THIS
AFTERNOON.
WWE ROBERT ALREADY
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME. MISTER
ROBERT RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK FOR YOUR GERMAN
THE MEMORY AND MEMBERS. PLEASE
GIVE YOUR FULL ATTENTION TO
MYSTERY OF US THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- AND I DO RISE TO JOIN
IN MEMORY OF LONGTIME CATTLE
RANCHER A GIFTED WRITER AND
FORMER CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETER FROM SET
UP. HE IS THE SON OF FIRST AND
SECOND GENERATION IMMIGRANTS.
BORN AND RAISED IN THE COUNTY
OF SAN BENITO. MISTER PERCENT A
LIVED A LIFE OF SERVICE TO
OTHERS. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY WHERE HE
CONDUCTED UNDERGRADUATE
RESEARCH ON THE HISTORY OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY. MR BROUGH SAID A
JOINT UNITED STATES ARMY- IN
GERMANY FOR TWO YEARS. HE CAME
BACK TO THE I'D STATES. AND
TOOK OVER HIS CATTLE RANCHING
ENTERPRISE AND HE DID WHAT HE
LOVED TO DO. THE LOVE HE FELT
PERCENT NO COUNTY WAS
UNPARALLELED. IN FACT MISTER
RECETA PUBLISHED FOUR BOOKS HE
DOCUMENTED THE RICH HISTORY AND
STORY OF THE COUNTY SAN BENITO.
EVENTUALLY MR BROUGH SAID- HE
DECIDED TO SERVE HIS COMMUNITY.
AND HE RAN FOR OFFICE DURING
HIS TIME HERE THE STATE CAPITOL
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
HE ENJOYED. REPRESENTING HIS
DISTRICT WITH GREAT PRIDE SO
MUCH SO THAT HE BECAME KNOWN AS
THE COWBOY IN THE CAPITAL.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLEW SAID
A SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN
ROBERT AND JENNIFER JACK AND
NANCY BRUCELLA. AS WELL THE
ELEVEN GRAND CHILDREN. AGAIN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY JOIN
ME IN A JOINT AND IN THE
JOINING IN HIS MEMORY- AND THAT
IS A FORMER STATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETER WHO SAID. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MYSTERY OF S. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
KILEY. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I HAVE THE HONOR OF ADJOURNING
IN THE MEMORY OF ASSEMBLYMAN
ROBERT BOB KLEIN. BOB WAS BORN
AND RAISED IN SAN FRANCISCO
ALONG WITH HIS BROTHER JOHN AND
SISTER JANET. HE EARNED HIS
UNDERGRAD DEGREE AND MBA FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. AND SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES ARMY FROM
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE TO NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN. HE WENT ON TO WORK
IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND
LATER STARTED HIS OWN
ACCOUNTING FIRM BUT IT WAS
ALWAYS POLITICS THAT. STRUCK
BOB'S INTEREST. HE WAS ELECTED
TO THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND SERVED
FOR TEN YEARS. HE THEN SPENT
THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS AS A
LOBBYIST WHERE HE WAS AN AVID
ADVOCATE FOR TAXPAYERS. BOB
COMMEMORATED HIS TIME IN
POLITICS BY DISPLAYING PHOTOS
HE'D TAKEN WITH YOU WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT AND
GOVERNOR. EVER EVERY REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT GOVERNOR SINCE DWIGHT
EISENHOWER HE ALSO ENJOYED DUCK
HUNTING AND WATERFOWL AND
SHARED THIS PASSION WITH THE
SON BRUCE AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN.
BOB HELP SET UP THAT BUTTE SINK
ASSOCIATION AND WAS A LIFELONG
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION AND DUCKS
UNLIMITED. HE WAS EVEN RECENTLY
INDUCTED IN THE CALIFORNIA
WATER FOLLOW OUR WATER FOWL HOW
PUBLIC THING. I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF GETTING TO KNOW BOB
DURING MY TIME IN OFFICE HE WAS
A TREMENDOUS MENTOR TO ME AND
AS A RESIDENT OF PATE PALMERO
WHERE I VISIT OFTEN I'D OFTEN
GET TO CATCH UP WITH HIM AND-
HE'D ALWAYS THAT. NOTE THAT AS
A FORMER MEMBER OF THIS BODY
HE'S FORMERLY HONORABLE WAS
HIS. FAVORITE CATCH PHRASE AND
THAT IT WAS ALWAYS- ON. I
PRIVILEGE TODAY TO TALK TO HIM
AND TO REMINISCE ON- YOU KNOW
WHAT THE BODY WAS LIKE WHEN HE
WAS HERE AND THAT HE ALWAYS HAD
GOOD ADVICE FOR ME I AS TO WHAT
THE- THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF US
TO SERVE IN THIS. CHAMBER ARE I
ALSO I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
GETTING TO TAKE HIM ON A TOUR
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO I HAVE
THE CAPITAL HERE OF COURSE IT
WAS REALLY HIM GIVING ME THE TO
OUR- AROUND THIS BUILDING AND
HE SHARED ALWAYS FAVORITE
EXPERIENCES- AND- OTHER WORDS
OF WISDOM. BOB IS SURVIVED BY A
SON BRUCE HIS DAUGHTER KAREN
EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND WILL BE
SO VERY MISSED SO TODAY I
MISTER SPEAKER I ASK THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED THE MEMORY A FORMER A
SUPPLEMENT. BOB KLEIN. THANK
YOU MISS KELLY. MR GALLAGHER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. IT IS MY
BOTH MY HONOR AND WITH SADNESS
THAT I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. OF OUR FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA STAND STATE THEM.
WHO PASSED AWAY IN HIS HOME ON
AUGUST FIRST AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY ONE. STAM WAS A LIFELONG
NORTH STATE RESIDENT AND A
FIERCE ADVOCATE. FOR THE NORTH
STATE COMMUNITIES THAT HE KNEW
AND LOVED. HE HAD ONE OF THOSE
GREAT RADIO VOICES. AND
EVERYTHING THAT HE DID HE HAD A
REPUTATION FOR BEING A GENUINE
AND DOWN TO EARTH INDIVIDUAL.
AN AUTHENTIC AND NICE GUY
SOMEONE YOU'D WANT TO BE
FRIENDS WITH AS SOON AS YOU MET.
HE WAS BORN IN CHICO IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE WHERE HE
ATTENDED CHICO HIGH SCHOOL.
STAN HAD A LONG AND
DISTINGUISHED CAREER. HE BEGAN
BY SERVING HIS COUNTRY. IN THE
ARMY MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE IN BERLIN BEFORE
FINDING HIS TRUE CALLING IN
TELEVISION BROADCASTING WHERE
HE WORKED AS A DIRECTOR AND A
NEWS ANCHOR FOR KHSL TV IN
CHICO. STAM WAS ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND ACTUALLY SERVED
TWO DIFFERENT STINTS SERVING
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. TO
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. IN THE
ASSEMBLY STAN WAS KNOWN AS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE. FOR THE NORTH
STATE AND RURAL COMMUNITIES.
PERHAPS BEST KNOWN FOR HIS
ADVOCACY OF SPLITTING THE STATE.
HE SUCCESSFULLY PASSED THROUGH
THIS ACTUAL BODY THIS HOUSE A
MEASURE. I WOULD HAVE PUT
BEFORE THE VOTERS. A MEASURE TO
SPLIT THE STATE INTO THREE
STATES. BUT HE HAD MANY OTHER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDING
REFORMING AND STRENGTHENING
DRUNK DRIVING LAWS AND CREATING
THE STATE BROWN BAG PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE SURPLUS AND DONATED
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES TO LOW
INCOME SENIORS. HE ALSO MADE
HISTORY BY HELPING CALIFORNIANS
HAVE GREATER ACCESS TO STATE
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS VIA
LIVE STREAM. AFTER BEING
APPOINTED TO SERVE AS THE CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY TELEVISION
COMMITTEE BY THEN SPEAKER
WILLIE BROWN IN. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE. AFTER LEAVING THE
ASSEMBLY STAND SERVED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION. WHERE AS YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER HELP MODERATE MANY
DIFFERENT GUBERNATORIAL DEBATES
INCLUDING THE DEBATE BETWEEN
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS AND- SOON
TO BE AND FORMER GOVERNOR
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER. THE
ASSOCIATION STAY THEM TO LEAVE
THEM BECAUSE WAS KNOWN FOR
BEING US DISTINGUISH A
DISTINGUISHED BROADCASTER AND
STATESMAN WHO ALWAYS HAD A
REPUTATION FOR LISTENING TO
OTHERS OPINIONS. HAVING GENUINE
FRIENDSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THE RECORD
SEARCHLIGHT IN HIS OBITUARY
SAID HE WAS PROBABLY THE LAST
OF AN ERA POLITICIANS. AND I
HOPE IT WOULDN'T BE THE LAST.
WHO DIDN'T LET THEIR PARTY
AFFECT THEIR MEMBER THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH MEMBERS
ACROSS THE AISLE. STANNIS
REVIVED BY HIS WIFE REALLY TO
STATE THEM HIS KIDS DAVID STATE
THEM AND JENNIFER HEY JACK. AND
HIS STEP CHILDREN JESSICA ERIC
AND STEVE EPPERSON. HIS GRAND
AND GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. HE HAS
MORE IN A MISS BY MANY AND
LEAVES A POWERFUL LEGACY
THROUGH HIS SERVICE AND MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I'D LIKE TO
END BY QUOTING STAYS THE
STATE'S THEM'S TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT SORRY TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN COLUMN FROM RED BLUFF
DAILY NEWS. WHERE HE WAS A
REGULAR CONTRIBUTOR. UP INTO
HIS HIS DEATH. ENTITLED MY TAKE
ON DEATH. IN JUST NINE MONTHS I
WILL BECOME EIGHTY YEARS OF AGE
SHE SAID. I DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THAT OR ANY OTHER THING OVER
WHICH I HAVE VERY LITTLE
CONTROL. I SIMPL TELL MYSELF
TO THINK ABOUT TWO WORDS RATHER
THAN DEATH. THOSE WORDS ARE
TICTOC. TIME MARCHES ON YOU
KNOW. YOU ACTUALLY CANNOT STOP
IT THOSE TWO WORDS. IN REALITY
ITSELF ALWAYS BRING MY MIND
BACK TO A POSITIVE POSITION. MY
PERSONAL TIME IS THE ONLY REAL
THING OVER WHICH I CAN DO
SOMETHING. AND I PROMISED
MYSELF EACH AND EVERY DAY I
WILL MAKE THE BEST OF IT. HE
CERTAINLY DID JUST THAT. THANK
YOU AND I ASK MEMBERS THAT WE
CLOSE IN MEMORY OF OUR
COLLEAGUE A MEMBER OF THIS
GREAT LEGISLATURE STANLEY STATE
FARM. THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER
MISSED ALLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE
TODAY ALSO TO INJURE ANY MEMORY
OF A TRUE STATESMAN WHO WAS A
FIXTURE IN THE NORTH STATE
WHICH I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT
FORMER ASSEMBLYMAN STAND STATE
THEM RIVERS IN THE NORTH
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA INNOCENTLY
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. IT IS
TIME SERVING THIS BODY HE WAS A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE AGAINST DRUNK
DRIVING HELPING TO CRAFT MANY
LEGISLATIVELY FORMS THE REMAIN
IN EFFECT TO THIS DAY. HE WAS
ALSO HONORED TO SERVE ON
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN'S
COMMISSION ON DRUNK DRIVING.
STATE THEM WAS BELOVED IN HIS
COMMUNITY AND BROUGHT ATTENTION
TO THE NORTH STATE YOU NEED
UNIQUE CHALLENGES. HE HAS BEEN
SOMEONE THAT I'VE LOOKED UP TO
AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR HIS
SERVICE TO OUR REGION. HIS
EXAMPLE AS CONTINUED COMMITMENT
TO ENSURING THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE WELL
REPRESENTED. AND PERSONALLY HE
WOULD TEXT AND CALL ME AND SEND
ME HE'S THE WEEKLY NEWS.
ARTICLE EVERY WEEK AND JUST A
CONSTANT STEADFAST ENCOURAGER.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF. MY RACE
SO I AM SO GRATEFUL TO HIM.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
HONORING THE MEMORY OF STAND
STATE THEM. THANK YOU MISTER
ALI.
DR ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE WITH A
HEAVY HEART TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF SAN JOAQUIN CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER JOSE ORNELAS WHO
PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY ON
JULY NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
HE WAS FORTY THREE YEARS OLD.
MR ARE NOW US EMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES AT THE AGE OF
THIRTEEN FROM HOLLY SCHOOL
MEDICAL. HE WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT EDUCATION AND DEDICATED
HIS ENTIRE LIFE TO SERVING HIS
COMMUNITY. HE KNEW THE
EXPERIENCE OF WORKING IN THE
FIELD HE WAS ALSO A TUTOR AND
MENTOR AND WORKED AS A
SUBSTITUTE TEACHER. HE BECAME A
REAL ESTATE BUSINESS OWNERAND
AN AGENT AND ULTIMATELY HE WAS
ELECTED TO SERVE ON THE SAN
JOAQUIN CITY COUNCIL. AMONG HIS
MANY ACTIVITIES MR ORNELAS
CREATED AND ESTABLISHED THE
GROUP ARCO IRIS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FORMED TO SPUR
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT. THIS
NONPROFITS BUILD NEW
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OTHER NON
PROFITS AND IN DOING SO BROUGHT
MORE SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY
OF SAN JOAQUIN. HE ALSO WAS A
MEMBER OF THE WATER EDUCATION
FOR LATINO LEADERS AND ONE OF
HIS PROUDEST. ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WAS THE- L. OF EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FRESNO COUNTY
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE THEM
WITH CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
MR ORNELAS WAS A MAN WHO HAD
THE ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
LIVES OF MANY. HE WAS A FIGHTER
AND HE TAUGHT US WHAT IT WAS
THAT WHEN YOU WANT SOMETHING
THAT YOU WORK FOR IT HE TAUGHT
US THAT THE WORD NO ONLY MEANS
THAT YOU KEEP TRYING. HE WAS A
PROUD FATHER HUSBAND SON AND
FRIEND AND HE ALWAYS
REPRESENTED THE COMMUNITY WITH
PRIDE AND DIGNITY. LET US SEND
OUR PRAYERS AND CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY AND I ASKED THE WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF WHOLE SAY
ORNELAS. THANK YOU DR ABDULLAH.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. VERY
MUCH A MISTER SPEAKER DR MELBA
A JURY TO GADI WAS BORN ON
MARCH THE THIRD NINETEEN
NINETEEN IN THE PHILIPPINES TO
SIMPLY SELL A GARY AND A
COLOSSAL PAN NADA. MELBA WAS
THE OLDEST OF FIVE SIBLINGS
EDUCATION AND LEARNING WERE
ALWAYS PRIORITIES FOR MELBA SHE
LEARNED SHE EARNED A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE ALL OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN
EDUCATION FROM THE PHILIPPINE
NORMAL SCHOOL. WHILE AT THE
UNIVERSITY MELBA MET HER FUTURE
HUSBAND THE LATE ATTORNEY THE
MINUTE OR TWO GODI WHO WAS
ATTENDING LAW SCHOOL NEARBY IN
MANILA AND WHOM SHE MARRIED ON
MARCH THE SECOND NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. MELBA WENT ON TO PURSUE
GRADUATE EDUCATION AT THE IOWA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND IN THE U.
K. AND RECEIVED A MASTER OF
ARTS DEGREE IN EDUCATION FROM
FAR EASTERN UNIVERSITY IN
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE. SHE LATER
RECEIVED THE R. PHD DEGREE IN
STATISTICS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SANTO TOMAS. MELBA USED HER
EDUCATION TO ADVOCATE FOR
IMPROVE ACCESS AND QUALITY OF
EDUCATION. BEFORE TRAVELING THE
WORLD TO MEET EDUCATORS AND
RAISED FUNDS FOR CHILDREN
ACROSS SOUTHEAST ASIA FOR THE
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY
CENTER IN SOUTHEAST ASIA. OVER
WOULD GO ON TO BECOME A
PROFESSOR FOR THE PHD PROGRAM
AT ARIANO UNIVERSITY AND
MANILA. MELBA AND DOMINO NO ART
JOINT THEIR CHILDREN AND LOS
ANGELES IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
THEY WERE ACTIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND VOLUNTEER FOR
MANY YEARS AT THE HOSPITAL
WHICH YOU WOULD PROVIDE MUCH OF
THEIR CARE LATER IN LIFE. AT
THE SAME GABLE VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER. I BELIEVE THE ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE YEARS OLD HER
SECRETS TO LONG LIFE INCLUDED
HER POSITIVE OUTLOOK. OVER THE
TOP GENEROSITY KINDNESS LOVE OF
LEARNING AND HER SINCERE DESIRE
TO HELP PEOPLE AROUND HER
WITHOUT ANY GAIN. OR
EXPECTATION OF SOMETHING IN
RETURN. SHE WAS HIGHLY EDUCATED
ACCOMPLISHED STRONG FOCUSED AND
A LOVING WIFE MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER FRIEND AND A MENTOR
MELBA PASSED AWAY AT HOME IN
HER SLEEP ON JUNE FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY. IN SAN GABRIEL
CALIFORNIA SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER FOUR CHILDREN THELMA ISABEL
TO RECEITA AND THE MINOTAUR
JUNIOR AND NUMEROUS
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH MISS SPEAKER.
THANK
YOU MICHELLE. DR WEBER. YOU.
AND COLLEAGUES ARE RECOGNIZED.
FOR YOUR ENJOYMENT IN MEMORY.
YES MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AND MANY OF THE OTHERS
MEMBERS WILL ALSO ADDRESS IT IN
MEMORY OF A LOSS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN TERMS OF A VERY DEAR FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE IN THE PERSON OF
WIN MORE- WHEN ONE LEFT THIS
HOUSE OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO BUT SHE LEFT A REMARKABLE
LEGACY OF WHAT YOU ACCOMPLISHED.
SHE AWAY TO OUR SURPRISE IN
AUGUST THE NINETEENTH. AND WE
WERE ALL SET IN LAST WEEK TO
HEAR HER UNTIMELY DEATH.
ACCORDING TO THE ARCHIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. WIN MORE PAPERS
FROM HER TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY
OCCUPIES TWENTY FIVE CUBIC FEET.
SHE WAS ONE OF THE MOST
PROLIFIC AND WIDE RANGING
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE WITH
AN ASTOUNDING FOUR HUNDRED BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW. DURING HER
SIXTEEN YEAR TENURE OF.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. MOST OF
US IF WE SERVE TWELVE YEARS
WOULD NOT EVEN GET CLOSE TO IT
FOR EVEN INTRODUCING FOUR
HUNDRED BILL BILLS NOT TALKING
ABOUT HAVE FOUR HUNDRED OF THEM
PASSED. FOR LEGISLATIVE LEGACY
INCLUDES PROCUREMENT
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE ACCESS
TO WOMEN. THE MINORITIES TO
STATE CONTRACTS SHE ALSO
INTRODUCED EIGHT MAJOR BILLS
THAT EXTENDED UNPAID FAMILY AND
PARENTAL LEAVE FOR CALIFORNIA-WORKERS TO CARE FOR A NEWBORN
OR NEWLY ADOPTED CHILD FOR
SERIOUSLY ILL CHILD FOR PEER TO
GRANDPARENTS ARE ELDERLY OR
ELDERLY SPOUSE. HE SERVED AS
THE CHAIR OF THE TILDES IN
COMMERCE COMMITTEE FOR OVER A
DECADE BECOMING AN EXPERT IN
PARTICULAR ON
TELECOMMUNICATIONS POLICY. HER
NAME SAKE THE MORE UNIVERSAL
TELEPHONE ACT. SECURE THE
AVAILABILITY OF TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE STILL USE
TODAY. THERE'S SO MUCH THAT WE
COULD ABOUT WIN MORE BUT MY
COLLEAGUES WILL ADDRESS THE
MOST SANDERS WILL ADDRESS IT.
DO WHEN WHAT AS A VERY DEAR
FRIENDS TO ALL OF US. SHE
WORKED HARD ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS. AND ALMOST EVERY
LAST ONE OF US IS IN A BIT
IMPACTED BY SOMETHING SHE'S
DONE. THAT HAS HAD A LASTING
IMPACT. I REMEMBER I WALKED
INTOA GROCERY STORE AND I WAS
SHOCKED TO DISCOVER THAT THEY
HAD RESTROOMS IN THE GROCERY
STORE. AND I SAID HOW DO WE GET
THESE RESTROOMS THEY SAY NGUYEN.
AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN. AT THE TIME
THIS AS A BILL. AND AS REST AS
IN ITS DOORS WERE BUILT AND
RENOVATED THEY HAVE TO
ACCOMMODATE PEOPLE NEEDED TO GO
TO THE RESTROOM. SAYS YOU'RE
GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE TO
SHOP. AND YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE
RESTROOM. YOU NEED TO THANK
GLENMORE. THAT WAS A PART OF
HER LEGISLATION. SHE WAS A
FRIEND TO EVERY MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. NOT A ONE OF US CAN
REMEMBER EVER HAVING TO ATTEND
A MAJOR EVENT. AND WHEN MOORE
WAS NOT THERE. WHAT IS THE
NOBEL WOMEN ORGANIZATION OR
WHETHER IT'S A BLACK
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS OF THE
NATION AWARE THAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. THE WEATHER
WAS JUST A BLACK CAUCUS EVENT.
WIN NEVER FORGOT THAT SHE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE BLACK CAUCUS. AND
WE'VE HAD OVER A FIFTY SOME ODD
MEMBERS OF THAT A BIT MEMBERS
OF OR MAYBE MORE THINK. OF A
HUNDRED I THINK THAT HAVE BEEN
A MEMBERS OF THE BLACK CAUCUS
FIFTY MEMBERS. WHEN WAS THE ONE
MEMBER. THAT EVERY LAST ONE OF
US KNOWS. SHE'S THE ONE MEMBER
WHO ATTENDS ALL OF OUR EVENTS.
AND PARTICIPATE IN OUR EVENTS
AND HAS BEEN A MENTOR TO EVERY
LAST ONE OF US. WE ARE
HEARTBROKEN OVER HER DEATH. BUT
WE FEEL BLESSED BY HER
PRESENCE. SO I ADDRESS THIS
HOUSE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF
ONE OF OUR MOST PROLIFIC
LEGISLATORS IN ALL TIME. WHEN
MORE. OF THE COLLEAGUES WILL
ADDRESS MORE OTHER ASPECTS OF
HER LIFE BUT WE ARE SADDENED.
AND WE WANT TO SEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO HER FAMILY. ON
HER LAW ON HER LOSS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU JUDGE WEBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KAMLAGER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS IN GERMANY
MEMORY. YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOING
MORE SHE WAS A LONG TIME AND A
VERY ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE FIFTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. BORN
RAISED AND EDUCATED IN LOS
ANGELES SHE ROSE FROM STUDENT
TO TEACHER TO PROFESSOR TO
BEING ELECTED TO THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD
AND THEN TO THE ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. SHE WAS
TRULY AN ICON OF THE
LEGISLATURE SHE WAS A POWERFUL
ADVOCATE A DEDICATED PUBLIC
SERVANT AN EXCEPTIONAL LEADER.
KNOWING HER WAS AN HONOR AND
HER IMPACT ON CALIFORNIANS AND
ESPECIALLY BLACK WOMEN
INTERESTED IN PUBLIC SERVICE
WILL LIVE ON FOR GENERATIONS.
YOU KNOW MISS MORE NEVER
ABANDONED WHO SHE WAS OR WHERE
SHE CAME FROM. USING TAX LOT A
SPONSOR PROGRESSIVE LEGISLATION
AIMED AT ELIMINATING RACIAL.
GENDER AND OTHER FORMS OF
BIGOTRY AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE
SHE RETIRED FROM PUBLIC OFFICE
SHE HAD MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
LAWS ON THE BOOKS TO HER NAME.
SHE LEFT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR AFTER MORE THAN A DECADE
OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS A
DEMOCRAT. SHE WAS THE ONE OF
THE MOST MOST POWERFUL MAJORITY
WHIP SEN AS WAS ALSO MENTIONED
THE MORE ACT WHICH IS STILL
WITH US REQUIRED THE STATE'S
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
PROVIDE LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
WITH ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
TELEPHONE SERVICE. IN ADDITION
TO HER ROLE AS AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHE SERVED AS THE FIRST
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CONFERENCE. OF
THE N. DOUBLE ACP COAST VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA UTILITY
DIVERSE CITY COUNCIL AND CHAIR
OF THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF
STATE LEGISLATURES. NATIONAL
COMMITTEE ON TELECOMMUNICATION
AND TRANSPORTATION. FOLLOWING
HER TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE
MISS MORE FOUNDED JAM
COMMUNICATIONS GROUP. A PUBLIC
RELATIONS FIRM FOCUSED ON
LEGISLATIVE STRATEGY AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH. YOU KNOW
SHE WAS AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
IN THE LOS ANGELES AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN'S PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE AS- I MENTIONED SHE
WAS AN ACTIVE CONSTITUENTS YOU
KNOW THE PHONE NUMBER TO THE
DISTRICT AND SHE WOULD CALL ALL
THE TIME. DEMANDING HER
SERVICES SHE WASN'T ENGAGE
MENTOR SHE WAS SUPPORTIVE. OF
BLACK WOMEN RUNNING FOR OFFICE
AND SERVING BECAUSE SHE FIRMLY
BELIEVED THAT IT WAS THE WOMEN
THAT DIDN'T HOST OF THE HEAVY
LIFTING IN THE HARD WORK UP
HERE. AND SHE WAS NOT AFRAID TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT. SHE WAS
LOVED BY SO MANY PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE IN LOS ANGELES AND
HERE. IN THE CAPITAL FAMILY AND
SO MANY OF US IN THE BLACK
CAUCUS. RECEIVED TAX OF SHOCK
AND SADNESS AT THE HEARING OF
HER PASSING. IT WAS AWESOME.
AND OVERWHELMING. TO JUST KNOW
HOW DEEPLY AND HOW PROFOUND HER
REACH WAS FOR SO MANY FOLKS WHO
STARTED HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
LEARN THE TRADE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. ALL WITH HER MENTOR
SHIP AND GUIDANCE YOU KNOW SHE
WAS SHE WAS SMALL IN STATURE
SHE WAS A PETITE WOMAN BUT SHE
WAS A FIRECRACKER. SHE WAS
DYNAMIC SHE WAS QUICK WITTED
SHE PULLED NO PUNCHES SHE MADE
YOU FEEL BAD IF YOU WERE NOT ON
YOUR TOES- AND SHE WAS JUST.
EMBRACED BY ALL SOME OF US AS
MEMBERS OF THE BLACK CAUCUS
THOSE CURRENT MEMBERS AND THOSE
FORMER MEMBERS AND- I THINK THE
WHOLE- HAS BEEN LEFT IN THE
HEARTS OF ALL OF US BECAUSE OF
HER PASSING WHICH IS WHY SO
MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CAUCUS WILL BE RISING TO SPEAK
OF HER SHE WAS SHE WAS LIKE
FAMILY TOO MANY OF US AND SHE
WAS FAMILY TO SOME OF US FOR
SURE- SHE IS GONE BUT MISS MORE
WILL DEFINITELY. NOT EVER EVER
EVER BE MISSED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE HAD JOHN IN THE
MEMORY OF FORMER ASSEMBLYWOMAN
AND CONSTITUENT OF THE FIFTY
FOURTH. MATH WHEN MORE. THANK
YOU MS KAMLAGER MS BURKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY. I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF ASSEMBLY
WOMAN PLAN MORE. IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I DO THAT
WITH MY COLLEAGUES SITTING.
WHEN WAS MORE THAN A FRIEND SHE
WAS. A CHERISHED AND TRUSTED
CONFIDANTE. SHE REALLY WAS MY
FAMILY. I WANT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED SHE WAS SMALL IN
STATURE. BUT SHE WAS A FORCE OF
NATURE. AND SHE WAS RESPECTED
ACROSS THE STATE AND WHEN SHE
SPOKE PEOPLE LISTENED AND AS
MOST OF YOU KNOW I DON'T ALWAYS
LISTEN AND I ALWAYS LISTEN TO
HER. WHEN INSTILLED IN ME THE
COURAGE AND CONVICTION TO FIGHT
FOR WHAT I BELIEVED IN. AND I
KNOW SHE HAS THE SAME EFFECT ON
SO MANY OTHER BLACK WOMEN
WHETHER THEY KNEW HER
PERSONALLY OR FROM AFAR. LIFE
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME WITHOUT
HER. AND I WILL MISS HER DEARLY.
I THINK ONE SO MUCH FOR THE
YEARS OF MENTORSHIP AND LOCAL.
FOR ALL THE TALKS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY FOR THE TOUGH LOVE.
FOR THE WISDOM AND THAT SHE
GAVE ME. AND SO MANY OTHERS I
WILL MISS HER EVERY DAY THANK
YOU FOR JOINING IN MEMORY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOT MORE. THANK
GOODNESS FOR MISTER GIBSON. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS A GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'D TO RISE
TO LEND MY VOICE TO THE CHORUS
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO TALKED ABOUT
THIS FIVE FOOT. FOUR STATUE OF
A WOMAN BY THE NAME OF GRAND
MORE. HER NAME WILL RING LOUD
THROUGH THE CALL TO THE HALLS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE. HER WORK
THAT SHE HAS DONE LANDMARK
LEGISLATION WILL BE PUT EVER IN
EXT IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I TO HAVE STORIES
OF THIS FIVE FOOT FIVE STATUE
OF A WOMAN THAT I WAS AFRAID
OF. I WAS AFRAID BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO DISAPPOINT HER I
DID WAS AFRAID BECAUSE SHE
EXPECTED. AS WE MATRICULATED
THOSE WERE AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
THIS OFFICE A POSITION WHICH
SHE HELD- IN HIGH ESTEEM AND WE
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE IN
THIS PLACE THAT WE HAD TO MAKE
SURE COMMUNITY CAME FIRST. AND
SHE DEMANDED THAT WE SPEAK
TRUTH TO POWER AND SO I ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUES WILL MISS.
THIS GREAT FIGHTER FOR JUSTICE
IN CALIFORNIA BY THE NAME OF A
GRAND MORE THE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN EVEN IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WERE. PLEASE KNOW THEY SHE SAID
IN THIS HOUSE PLEASE NOTE AS
SHE WALKED IN THIS GREEN CARPET
PLEASE NOTE SHE HAVE CREATED
LANDMARK LEGISLATION THAT WILL
BE PERCEIVED FOR YEARS TO COME
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE NOTE YOU HAVE NOT HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET HER I WOULD
INVITE YOU TO JUST GOOGLE HER
AND LOOK AT SOME OF THE
LANDMARK LEGISLATION LOOK HOW
MANY PEOPLE SHE HAVE SERVED AND
I WAS SIMPLY COULD CO CONCLUDE
BY SIMPLY SAYING THIS. WE ALL A
DATE OF BIRTH ON OUR TOMBSTONE
AND THEN A DATE THAT WE PASSED
AWAY. BUT IT WHAT REALLY COUNTS
IN THE MIDDLE AND CERTAINLY SHE
HAS LIVED HER DASH- NOBILI SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE NAME OF GLENMORE.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON. WITHOUT
A. I'M SORRY MR HOLDEN YOU TOO
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I. NOT ADD TOO MUCH MORE TO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
DESCRIBED. IN THE LIFE IN THE
LEGACY OF WHEN MORE. I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF. FOLLOWING GOING
MORE IN THE SENSE THAT. SHE
SERVED IN A VERY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE. MEDICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE BUT UTILITY AND
ENERGY. AND THIS IS A BEEN A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK TO HER. FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND GUIDANCE
SOMETIMES WITHOUT ASKING FOR
BUT CLEARLY KNOWING THAT WHEN
SHE OPENED HER MOUTH. THEN
SHARED HER THOUGHTS IT WAS
DRAWN ON EXPERIENCE. IS DRAWN
ON TECHNICAL UNDERSTANDING AND
A VERY TECHNICALLY DRIVEN
SUBJECT MATTER. I WAS ALWAYS
VERY PROUD OF HER. AND SHE WAS
VERY PROUD OF ME. AND TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT. SHE WAS A
FRIEND. SHE WAS A CONFIDANTE.
SHE WAS A MENTOR. SHE WAS
SOMEONE THAT. LAID A FOUNDATION.
FOR PEOPLE TO FOLLOW BEHIND.
AND UNDERSTAND AS A PERSON OF
COLOR. AND AS A FEMALE. AT THAT
TIME THE KIND OF CHANGES THAT
SHE WAS MAKING. YOU CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THE RESISTANCE AND SHE
WAS UP AGAINST. AND AS DR WEBER
WAS POINTED OUT HOW MANY BILL
SHE PASSED. WITH THAT KIND OF
RESISTANCE AGAINST HER. MIXER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANT. WHEN I WAS CHAIR
OF THE CAUCUS. WE CELEBRATED
OUR FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY. WHEN
MORE WOULD. BE A PART OF JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING WE DID TO
RECOGNIZE THE LEGACY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. AND
SHE WAS SOMEONE WHO. CAME TO
EVER EVENT THAT WE PUT. BECAUSE
SHE AS MUCH AS WE WERE
RECOGNIZING. THE LEADERS OF THE
PAST
THOSE WHO FOLLOW. AND THAT THAT
LEGACY WAS CONTINUING. AND SO
IT WAS WITH GREAT PRIDE THAT I
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES TODAY.
AND RECOGNIZING A TRUE LEGEND.
SOMEONE WHO SET THE BAR SO HIGH
I'M NOT SURE ANY OF US IN THE
CAUCUS TODAY IF WE COMBINED OUR
AGENDA OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
TO GET TO ANYWHERE CLOSE WHICH
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH.
SHE WILL BE GREATLY MISSED AND
SHE WILL BE GREATLY LOVED.
THANK YOU MISTRIAL THAN MR
JONES SAWYER YOU TOO ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I TO RISE IN MEMORY
OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOING MORE.
WHO AS YOU CAN HEAR FROM
VARIOUS MEMBERS OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS. SHE WAS DEFINITELY A
MENTOR TO ALL OF US. EVEN THOSE
OF US WHO ARE ALWAYS ON THE
SAME SIDE OF AN ISSUE. OR ON
THE SAME SIDE OF SOMEONE
SUPPORTING SOMEONE. BUT I WILL
TELL YOU AS SOMEONE WHO EVEN
RAN AGAINST QUINN MORE. AND.
SHE WAS REAL HAPPY ABOUT THE
OUTCOME. BUT SHE WAS A TOTAL
PROFESSIONAL AND EVEN THOUGH WE
MAY HAVE SOME DIFFERENCES. EACH
TIME I NEEDED ADVICE SHE WOULD
GIVE IT TO ME. EVEN WHEN I
DIDN'T EAT ADVICE SHE WOULD
GIVE ME CRITICAL ADVICE ON WHAT
I NEEDED TO DO TO MOVE FORWARD
NOT ONLY IS ELECTED OFFICIAL
BUT AS A PERSON. SOMETHING THAT
I WILL ALWAYS APPRECIATE I HAVE
FRIENDS FOR EXAMPLE. THAT
CALLER ID GRANT. THAT'S HOW
BELOVED SHE IS IN OUR OWN
DISTRICT IN THE FORTY SEVENTH
BACK THEN IT WAS THE FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. AND
EVEN TO THIS DAY THERE PEOPLE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THE STILL
CALL HER AUNTIE GRANT. SO I
THREE RIVERA HAS THE AUDIBLE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHEN MORE I
WANTED TO ADD THAT SHE'S ALSO
BELOVED. IN HER DISTRICT. SHE'S
BELOVED IN THE COMMUNITY AND
SHE'S BELOVED BY OUR FAMILY AND
THAT IS PROBABLY MORE
IMPORTANT. THAN THAN ANYTHING
ELSE TO KNOW THAT. PEOPLE
GENERALLY LOVE BEING AROUND YOU
AND THEY ADMIRED YOU THE MOST
IMPORTANT. HER ADVICE IS GOING
TO BE SORELY MISSED THE MISS
FROM EVERY MEMBER OF THE BLACK
CAUCUS BECAUSE EVERY TIME SHE
SPOKE TO YOU. IT WAS A PEARLS
OF WISDOM. AND WE WILL TRULY
MISTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON THANK YOU
MEMBERS. MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY FATHER
IN LAW. URNESS FOR GHOSAL.
EARNERS GREW UP IN A FAMILY OF
HARD WORKING PEOPLE. HE WAS THE
MIDDLE CHILD OF THREE SONS BORN
TO FRANK AND AT LEAST GIVE IT A
GO SO. HE CAME FROM A FAMILY
WHO WERE THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY. THEY WOULD TAKE OVER
RESTAURANTS AND GET THEM BACK
INTO SHAPE. HE WAS ALL LEASE
KIND TO STRANGERS AND WILLING
TO HELP PEOPLE IN NEED. WHEN
RELATIVES WOULD COME FROM
MEXICO TO CALIFORNIA HE WOULD
FIND THEM A JOB AND A PLACE TO
LIVE. ERNEST MARRIED THE LOVE
OF HIS LIFE IN NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. HE WAS NINETEEN AND SHE
WAS SEVENTEEN. THEIR MARRIAGE
PRODUCED SEVEN CHILDREN THREE
SONS AND FOUR DAUGHTERS. THEY
WERE BOTH GREAT LEADERS WHO MAY
HAVE GROWN UP IN SIMPLER TIMES
BUT EXPERIENCE MANY HARDER
TIMES THEY INVESTED IN THEIR
CHILDREN TO PROVIDE WHAT THEY
DID NOT HAVE TO THEIR CHILDREN
GROWING UP. EARNERS HAD MANY
TALENTS MOSTLY AS A SALESMAN.
THOUGH HE DID NOT OBTAIN A FOR
FORMAL EDUCATION HE DID NOT
LACK IN CONFIDENCE DRIVE AND
DETERMINATION. THIS COMMAND OF
ENGLISH WASN'T THE BEST. BUT IT
DIDN'T STOP HIM FROM GOING INTO
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS TO GO OUT
AND MEET OTHER PEOPLE AND
CREATE RELATIONSHIPS. WHEN HIS
CHILDREN WENT ON BUSINESS TRIPS
WITH HIM THEY OBSERVED HIM
GOING INTO BUSINESSES INTRODUCE
HIMSELF WINNING THE OWNERS
TRUST MAINTAINING THAT TRUST
AND SUPPORTING BUSINESSES WITH
NEW IDEAS AND BRINGING IN NEW
INCOME. THAT WAS APPRECIATED
AND BADLY NEEDED. HE MADE IT
APPEAR EASY BUT IT MUST HE MUST
HAVE HAD A PUSH THROUGH HIS
FEAR TO GET THROUGH IT.
UNFORTUNATELY EARNERS HELP.
WASN'T THE BEST. BUT HE HAD
MANY CARETAKERS IN THE FAMILY.
ALICE AND FAMILY TO GREAT PRIDE
IN TAKING CARE OF HIM. AT THE
END OF JUNE OUR FAMILY WAS
INFORMED THAT HIS LUCK HAD RUN
OUT AND THAT HE HAD CONTACTED
QUOTED NINETEEN. AFTER PERIOD
OF REPORTING NO SYMPTOMS THEY
DISCOVERED THAT THERE WERE
SYMPTOMS THAT THEY HAD MESSED.
AND HIS PASSING CAME QUICKLY.
EARNERS WAS SPECIAL AND HIS
LEGACY WILL LIVE ON. HE REMINDS
US TO BE KIND TO EACH OTHER. TO
SEE SOMEONE IN NEED TO HELP
THEM. ERNEST IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE ALICE DAUGHTERS LINDA
KAREN PATRICIA. AND CRISTINA
SONS BERNIE BRANDON AND MARK
ELEVEN GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
MY FATHER IN LAW EARNERS FOR
GHOSTS. THANK YOU MR MEDINA
ISRAEL'S. YOUR RECORD OKAY
THANK YOU MS REYES THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA. WITHOUT
OBJECTION DR EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
AMERICAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AT TODAY I
RISE TO ASK HIS HOUSE TO
ADJOURN IN THE HONOR OF THE
FOUR SOLDIERS THAT WERE KILLED
ON JULY THIRTIETH IN A-
AMPHIBIOUS ASSAULT THEM. SINK
H. BOMB OF THEIR OF THEIR- AND
BIGGEST BEAGLE. THAT IS- PSC
BYRON BELL CHAIR OF CORONA
CORPORAL MARCO BAROCCO OF
MONTEBELLO CESAR VILLANUEVA A
RIVERSIDE. AND CHRISTOPHER
BOBBY YEAH I'M OF STOCKTON-
BOBBY AS HE WAS KNOWN TO HIS
FAMILY WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. LIFETIME STOCK
TONI AND BORN AND RAISED
ATTENDED STOCKTON SCHOOLS. HE
DISCOVERED HIS ISSUE AND JUDO
AND FOOTBALL AND THEN FELL IN
LOVE WITH BASKETBALL DURING HIS
HIGH SCHOOL. EIGHT FOUR YEARS
OF HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL
BECAME THE TEAM CAPTAIN. AND HE
FIRST SOUGHT OUT A COLLEGE
COUNSELOR AT THAT HIGH SCHOOL
AND SHE ASKED HIM WHAT HE
WANTED TO DO WITH HIS LIFE IN
COLLEGE AND HE SAID I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I WANT TO DO EXCEPT
TAKE CARE MY MOM. SO THE
COLLEGE COUNSELOR CALLED HIS
MOM TO LET HIM KNOW WHAT A FINE
YOUNG MAN HE HAD RAISED AND-
THE RECRUITER CAME TO THE
CAMPUS AND HE BECAME INTRIGUED
JOIN THE MILITARY AND SERVING.
SOMETHING GREATER THAN HIMSELF.
HIS MOM ENCOURAGED HIM TO GO IN
THE NAVY THINKING THAT WOULD BE
THE SAFEST WAY FOR HIM TO GO.
SO HE JOINED THE NAVY. M. UP
AMEDICA CORPORATION LIKE MYSELF
AND WENT TO. A FORT SAM HOUSTON
TEXAS FOR HIS TRAINING. HE WAS
THEN STATIONED AT CAMP
PENDLETON. WHERE HE THEY WENT
OUT ON A MISSION. HE WAS WITH.
FOURTEEN OTHER PEOPLE. SEVEN
OTHER MARINES DIED AND HE DIED
AS WELL AS THE ONLY NAVAL
CORPSMAN IN THE IN THE I SAW A
VEHICLE THAT TOOK ON WATER
SHORTLY OFF SHORE- WE LAID HIM
TO REST YESTERDAY AND IN
STOCKTON WITH FULL MILITARY
HONORS WE OFFER CONDOLENCES TO
THE FAMILY OF ALL THE SAILORS
AND SOLDIERS AND MARINES. WHO
DIED ON THAT DAY AND WHEN THEY
RAISE THEIR HAND AND SIGNED UP
BLANK CHECK EVEN WHEN THEY'RE
OFF THE SHORE OF CALIFORNIA
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE TO SERVE THIS COUNTRY
AND WE ASK THIS HOUSE STAND. IN
THEIR ADJOURNMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR EGGMAN. IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION MISS CRISTINA GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU I
WANTED TO DO I JOIN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN STOCKTON IN
RACING IN MEMORY OF OUR FALLEN
SOLDIERS SAW AND THAT ACTION
THEIR FOURTEEN MARINES FROM
ACROSS THE NATION INCLUDING.
LANCE CORPORAL MARCO BUT I'M
GOAL OF MONTEBELLO. IN MY
DISTRICT. LANCE CORPORAL BUT
I'M BECAUSE MOM TO BE THAT CS
AT HER SON ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
A SOLDIER THAT HE WAS LIVING.
HIS DREAM. SHE SAID HER SON WAS
INSPIRED TO SERVE HIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
THEY GAVE HIS IMMIGRANT PARENTS
AND FAMILY. MARGOLIS A KIND
HEARTED PERSON WITH A LOT OF
LOVE TO SHARE. HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN LA AND MOVED TO THE
CITY OF MONTEBELLO WHERE YOU
WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL. MARK ALSO
KNOWN AS ANDY. I IS LED BY IS
LET THIS FAMILY HIS FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. HE WAS ALWAYS
WILLING TO HELP AND THEN AT
ANYONE A HELPING HAND. HIS MOM
SAID I'M SO PROUD OF YOU. YOU
ARE THE BEST AND I COULD HAVE
ASKED FOR. MY HEART GOES OUT TO
ALL THE FAMILIES BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS MY SON WHO IS LOST. BUT
I AM PLEASED BEHIND TWO SISTERS
ANNES A NUMBER NEPHEW AND BOTH
OF HIS PARENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS GARCIA. MR MEDINA IN
YORK AND RECOGNIZE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND ROBERT
TAYLOR. KNOWN TO HIS FRIENDS AS
BOB. PASSED AWAY QUIETLY
EARLIER EARLIER THIS MONTH. BOB
RECEIVED HIS B. S. AND JD
DEGREES OF CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
LAW SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE. BOB
SPENT HIS ENTIRE CAREER
INCREASING HIS EXPERTISE IN
HANDLING WORKERS COMPENSATION
CASES ON BEHALF OF INJURED
WORKERS HIS STATUS A REPUTATION
AS ONE OF THE PREEMINENT
APPLICANT ATTORNEYS NOT ONLY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BOB WAS ALSO STRONG
SUPPORTER AND ADVOCATE FOR
ORGANIZED LABOR IN CALIFORNIA.
WELL KNOWN AND HIGHLY REGARDED
BY THE RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND THE CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL. BUT MORE THAN HIS
PROFESSIONAL ACHIEVEMENTS BOB
VALUED AT THE TIME THAT HE
WOULD SPEND WITH HIS FAMILY IT
WAS VERY PRESENT IN THE
COMMUNITY COACHING HIS
CHILDREN'S SPORTS. VOLUNTEERING
FOR HABITAT FOR HUMANITY AND
PARTICIPATING ON SEVERAL SCHOOL
BOARD FROM GRADE SCHOOL TO
COLLEGE. HE WAS AN OUT ABBOTT.
FISHERMEN HIKER AND LEAD TO
SHARE THOSE ACTIVITIES WITH HIS
GRANDCHILDREN AND EXTENDED
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. BOB IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE FOUR
CHILDREN AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA
AND MS RADIUS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE AND THE HOUSE
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY
DEAR FRIENDS OF OVER THIRTY
YEARS BOB TAYLOR. WE'RE BOTH
PRACTICING ATTORNEYS. BOTH
REPRESENTING INJURED WORKERS.
AS APPLICANTS ATTORNEYS HE WAS
THE LEADER NOT ONLY IN LONG AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION HE WAS A
PAST PRESIDENT OF OUR LOCAL
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION BUT HE
ALWAYS PUSHED FOR THE RIGHTS OF
WORKERS AND FOR THE PROTECTIONS.
AS NOTED EARLIER HE WAS A
VOLUNTEER WITH HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY ESPECIALLY TEACHING
HIS DAUGHTERS THE VALUE OF
WEARING A TOOL BELT AND HELPING
TO BUILD HOMES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
ONE OF THE THAT BOB DURING HIS
LIFETIME WAS TO WALK THE CAMINO
THE SANTIAGO IN SPAIN. HE
SHARED HOW THIS EXPERIENCE HAD
CHANGED HIS LIFE. BOB WAS AN
OUTSTANDING ATTORNEY AND AN
OUTSTANDING HUMAN BEING. AS A
PAST PRESIDENT OF OUR
ASSOCIATION SAID HE WAS A
VALLAS AND EFFECTIVE ADVOCATE
AND YET WE DO WOULD BE
CHALLENGED TO FIND ANYONE WITH
A CROSS WORD TO SAY ABOUT HIM
HE WAS THE MARVIN SHAPIRO OF
THE INLAND EMPIRE. BOB WAS A
CLASS ACT. HE WAS SMART IS
COMMITTED TO ITS CLIENTS. WHO
IS WILLING TO HELP COLLEAGUES
WITH LEGAL ISSUES. MOST
ESPECIALLY. BOB TAYLOR WAS
DEVOTED TO HIS FAMILY. AND HE
WAS A FIGHTER FOR JUSTICE. I
ALWAYS APPRECIATED HEARING HIM
REFERRED TO HIS WIFE ROSALYNN.
AS HER MAJESTY SHE WAS HIS
QUEEN. HE KNEW SHE RULED. MAY
HIS NEW JOURNEY BE PAVED WITH
PEACE. AND MAYES FAMILY AND
FRIENDS BECOME PRINTED WITH THE
MEMORIES OF BOB SMILE HIS LAUGH.
HIS COMMITMENT AND HIS FIGHT
FOR A BETTER WORLD. POLITICS I
ASKED WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MY FRIEND BOB TAYLOR. THANK YOU
MS REYES THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DEATHS REPORTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MISTER
CALDERON IS APPROACHING THE
RUSSIAN. THIS CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I MOVED TO TAKE UP A. B. THIRTY
TO THIRTY FOURTEEN WITH THE
REFERENCE FIVE THE PURPOSE OF
THIRD READING. MISTER FOR
PURPOSE SIR MS CONSENT ASPER
ROLL CALL VOTE. MISTER FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING. MEMBERS MISTER
CALDERON MOVES MR BONTA SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. HI
MISTER FLORA NO. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IN MISTER FLORA IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. ON THE
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES. THE
CLERK WILL. CALDERON I FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS. ELEVEN THAT MOTION
CARRIES. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RESCIND
THE ACTION WHEREBY SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO JACKSON WAS READ A
THIRD TIME PASS IN ORDER TO THE
SENATE ON SEPTEMBER TENTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IN ORDER THE
BILL TO THE THIRD READING FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE TO
TAKE OF AN ITEM THAT WE PASS
TEMPORARILY THIS IS FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE. SB. FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THE CORPORATION SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
CENTER ARCH ABOUT ANOTHER'S
ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS
MR WENT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT TO SB FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT CLOSES DAUGHTER
STATED THAT DATA GAPS IN THE
DISABLED VETERANS PROGRAM
ENTERPRISE PROGRAM. SO WE CAN
ANALYZE. THE PROGRAM PROPERLY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR ONE. SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CORPORATE.
IT IS OUT OF OUT OVER PROVIDERS
AT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH. WELL
CLOSER ROLE TIE THE BUT I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. MR CHANG'S
A. B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TO THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
MISTER CHANG THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER MAYBE THIRTY TO THIRTY
FOUR GIVES JUDGES THE
DISCRETION TO ALLOW INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED WITH MISDEMEANORS TO
INSTEAD TAKE PART IN DIVERSION
PROGRAM IT ALSO CHANGES THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR ELDERLY PAROLE
FROM SIXTY YEARS TO FIFTY YEARS
IN TIME SIR FROM TWENTY FIVE TO
TWENTY YEARS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO
REMOVE CONSIDERATION OF SEX
OFFENSES AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENSES. FROM THE REVERSION
PROGRAM NOTHING IN THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR AUTOMATIC RELEASE OF
ANY PRISONERS OR PEOPLE WHO
WERE ARRESTED FOR MISDEMEANORS
IT JUST GIVES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE EXPANDED INTO
THE IN THE PEARL PORTRAYAL TO
LEAVE OR TO HAVE JUDGES HAVE
DISCRETION TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO A
DIVERSION PROGRAM AND AGAIN
UNDER THIS BILL JUDGES HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO SEND A PERSON
WOULD BE BETTER SERVED WITH THE
REHABILITATIVE DIVERSION
PROGRAM INSTEAD OF ENTERING
INTO A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHEN THERE WAS A PILOT IN LOS
ANGELES WE SAW THAT COURT COSTS
UPWARDS COULD BE UP TO TWELVE
THOUSAND PER DAY TO HOLD AND
THE PROVIDED DIVERSION FOR MORE
THAN TWO THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD WHICH
SAVED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
ELDERLY PRISONERS AGE FIFTY
FIVE YEARS AND OLDER HAVE GROWN
NATIONALLY BY 5100% OF THE COST
OF MEDICAL CARE GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY ON AVERAGE THE
COST OF AN INMATEIS ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER FOR OUR
MOST ELDERLY. INMATES THE COST
COULD RUN UP TO TWO HUNDRED TO
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND- A STUDY
BY THE JUSTICE POLICY INSTITUTE
FROM THE RECIDIVISM. AGAIN THE
BILL DOES NOT RELEASE ANY
ELDERLY PERSON SUGGEST EXPANDS
THE NUMBER OF ELDERLY PRISONERS
WHO CAN GO IN FRONT OF THE
PAROLE BOARD I WOULD THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON P. B. THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER COOPER I RECOGNIZE. YEAH
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SISTER MOVES
ALL THE MISDEMEANOR STUFF FOR
THE- CORRECT. FOR THE JUDICIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM BE REMOVED-
THE CONSIDERATION OF SEX
OFFENSES AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENSES. OKAY IT'S GOTTEN
BETTER WITH THE WITH ON MY OWN
TIME NOW IT'S GOTTEN BETTER BUT
STILL YOU HAVE DO YOU LIVE WITH
INJURY- FIREARMS OFFENSES CARRY
FIREARM. LITTLE FARMING PUBLIC
BRING A DEADLY WEAPON THE STATE
BUILDING SO WELL IT'S A BETTER
BILL AND IT WAS- THEY'RE STILL
FINISHES AT AMMAN FORMALLY
OPPOSED TO IT. IT AND I'VE ALSO
DONE THE QUESTION FOR THE AFTER
THE AUTHOR. OF THE TOP RAFI
PORTIONS TAKEN OUT THAT
CORRECT. SIR THE POSITION ATOP
AN RV- THAT I BELIEVE SO YES.
MORE INTERESTING SO I NEED TO I
NEED TO BE SURE ON THAT PART
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO
GATHER. AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF GOOD AMENDMENTS THAT. MADE
THE BILL BETTER BUT- THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN
CHILD **** RIGHT NOW WE'RE
SEEING. IN THE TRANSITIVE ACTED
OUT MORE- DURING COVERT A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO LOVE THE VIEWS OF
CHILDREN. TAKE PLACE OBVIOUSLY
IF SOMEONE DOWNLOADING CHILD
**** THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE TO
ACT UPON THAT SO- JUST THEM
ISSUES FUNDAMENTALLY THAT. YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO GET THERE SO-
IT BE HELPFUL JUST NOTE THAT'S-
STILL A PORTION OF THE BILL OR
IF IT WAS BEEN REMOVED. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT. THAT
SHOULD NOT BE PART THE BILL ALL
THE SEX OFFENSES IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENSES WERE
ALL REMOVED. THAT'S MY- THAT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANKS COOPER SEEING. NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM MISTER
CHANG YOU MAY CLOSE YOUR WISH.
CARCLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS OF. IT
IS OUR ABOUT OUR MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A
DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOWEVER SERVICE
OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE OF THE I. TWENTY ONE
OF TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MISTER CALDERONYOU
REGARD RECOGNIZED HER SHE TO
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SIX TO A DEFAULT NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HERE SB
SEVEN THIRTY ONE BRADFORD NH
ARE ONE OF THREE STONE ON
WEDNESDAY UPON CALL THE CHAIR.
MR FLOOR FOR PURPOSE WE
WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT
NATURAL COLOR MR FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING MISTER CALDERON
MOVES MR BONTA SECONDS ON THE-
TRY ROSI'S PENSION FOR
COLLATERAL. CEDAR OF OTHER
PREPONDERANCE ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. INVESTOR FLORA NO MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE.
THE CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FORTY
EIGHT MINUTES FOURTEEN THE
RULES. ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL.
PREPARE TO LIFT A CALL ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY THREE S. B. ONE
FIFTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS AT
ABOUT. BURKE. CLERK WILL. THE
CLOSER ROLE. TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY THREE NOTES HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES. ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY. AUGUST TWENTY FIFTH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT TEN AM
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY SIX
FOUR SESSION IS UPON CALL OF
THE SPEAKER. THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH FOR SESSION
BEGINS. PROMPTLY AT NINE AM
FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH FOR
SESSION UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER. ALL OTHER ITEMS
MANNING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING AND HEARING A
FOR THE BUSINESS ARE READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOOSE M. MR GALLAGHER
SECONDS. THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL TUESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY FIFTH AT TEN AM. AND A
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.